une production du studio sf
bio sans fil le podcast on parle ce
comics nous inviter
des
jeunes adorent cette semaine soit le
pharmacien lui bernard c'est un régulier
de podcasts ont l'air vraiment beaucoup
ce n'est sa garde ses atouts monde en
parle dans la carte chouchou le sac à
chu-young
les retours
aujourd'hui on parle d'hallucinogènes en
fait l'idée de lancer son tout nouveau
podcast des riffs 5,2 à yahoo ask qui
parle des rituels en fait autour de
cette drogue hallucinogène de kizliar
basque est d'aider des gens qui vont
faire qui vont souvent pérou dans
certains pays fassent actuelle le est en
fait pour en apprendre plus sur
l'histoire de nelson qui est aux
québécois qui ont participé un rituel
comme ceux est qui et qui manque en fait
qui se sait qu'ils se seraient poignardé
le vent qui s'en seraient décédés alors
on veut essayer par la lumière
je vous recommande c'est vraiment
passionnant si vous avez encore écouter
dérive honnêtement
si vous n'avez pas déjà écouté qu'il
aurait mérité pas de carte puis on va
pas vous spoiler pis si vous l'avez
écouté peut-il aller encore plus tripes
et son pote qu'est-ce qu'on s'apprête à
revoir on parle de dieu mais on parle
aussi des hallucinogènes en général on
parle aussi de
la science d'ailleurs ce est ce que ça
peut être utilisé en thérapie menons on
parle on parle de certaines de nos
expériences aussi personnel
toujours intéressant on apprend toujours
énormément avec politiques ont pris pour
remercier assez
juste avant d'aller écouter la
conversation avec olivier on va les
remercie nos commanditaires le podcast
de cette semaine et présenté par idées
cadeaux québec qui est un site web qui
regroupe plusieurs produits d'ici du
québec qui permet de résoudre la plus
grande énigme du temps des fêtes en tout
cas en ce qui me concerne savoir quoi
acheter à la personne que j'ai pigé
pendant les champs aucun doute mais vous
allez sur qui des cadeaux quebec.com
vous pouvez chercher par soit pris soin
dessinateur avec par exemple des pumas
soient obligés orange en trente et
cinquante
deux compagnies d'ici sur des compagnies
qu'on connaît des jo des compagnies
commencent qu'on peut encourager
le site des conviviales l'ambiance était
conviviale effet utilisé libos aller là
dessus ça permet d'avoir accès en garde
a été produit sans avoir à se déplacer
ce téléphone se silvan surtout dans le
conte dans le contexte l'acolyte de on
veut rester chez nous une section pour
noël là dessus le top 50 des messes des
cadeaux noël pour 2021 le coin pour
enfants et en guise de cadeau donc et
vous allez trouver réponses à toutes vos
questions on peut le faire livrer
directement chez soi ou directement chez
la personne à qui vous offrir sept sur
dix magnifiques cadeaux et yappa
nouveauté pour noël alors il faut faire
vite parce que ça peut partir très
rapidement foscam d'avant ce préquel du
9 août comme moi à chaque année et se
réveiller le 23 décembre on se prend
davance alors allez sur le site du stade
au québec coin comme idée cadeau que des
idées cadeaux cas d'excès comment met-on
twister décréter des êtres trois fois
rapidement
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
police lui ont pas laissé pour les adore
les matelas et oreillers qu'on utilise
c'est absolument incroyable pour notre
sommeil ici vous avez manqué le black
friday ou le sabre mandjeck pas
d'inquiétude parce qu'on a un code pour
vous qui nous permet d'avoir 30 % de
rabais sur les propos les slips je
répète de 30% de rabais en six ans le
code seibel film c'est y b à effet elle
tr veut pourquoi tu 30% ses colonnes et
maintenant qu'est-ce que tu donnes
donne donne congé des douleurs
musculaires
d'allergie d'apnée du sommeil mandature
et que des problèmes de tous grâce à des
produits d'ici le chili fait au québec l
offre est incroyable l'offre est à
l'échec dans une eau sans titre
justement qui donne cet afflux
profitez-en du 30 au 6 200 tr novembre
se défend scheiber est beau et il
rembourse aof il dormait mieux
dormi police l'a
[Musique]
emporté au creux de ton pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là à nu ce qu'ils
avaient pu être prises
ailleurs merci
l'excitation aux petites séries la
saison de dérivés sortie 6 vendredi là
on est pour ceux qui nous écoutent ont
mené lundi fait que moi j'étais immergé
tout le week end dans l'histoire de
l'ayahuasca way
au complet c'est non mais cool mais
c'était un homme a premièrement
félicitations parce que c'est vraiment
moi la saison j'avais adoré ça puis tout
aussi bon la saison 2 pour que je trouve
ça vraiment
[Musique]
avancer dans le podcast du dépôt un
journaliste enquête mais
c'est le journal c'est off parce que je
peux pas dire que je fais une enquête
moi ça semble commune en kite même tâté
du journalisme d'enquêté de sa suite des
protocoles des procédures c'est complexe
le tir qui on dirait que de faire de
travailler là-dessus en fait ça m'a fait
beaucoup plus apprécié le journaliste
dans quelques mois je me rappelle est là
mais quand je regarde je me dis oh my
god de faire des vraies enquêtes comme
cela avec des délits dits des
ramifications légale des fois où est
cette erreur c'est vraiment impressionné
mais ça m'a fait beaucoup apprécié le
journaliste d'un autre temps un
sentiment d'imposture plus de faire une
joie dans quel sens à être en quête
je sais pas si c'est un poster et c'est
sûr qui est totalement faux que tu te
ramène c'est parce que la face et que
t'as pas est un rôle tout le temps avec
toi maintenant c'est comme si comme dans
l'histoire que le gie explorer on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé contrairement à
la saison 1 les l'histoire du rituel
utilisation on savait tout ce qui
s'était passé au début mon but ce n'est
pas de découvrir ce qui s'était passé le
service qui s'était passé et avait même
eu un procès piteux saison 2 c'est un
cas où on sait rien sauf que tout ait un
rôle de tête jeudi bataille semaine et
c'est peut-être ce qui s'est passé c'est
peut-être ça qui est magnifique tu te
ramène à un peuple le moins le je vais
pas m'improviser détective ou enquêteurs
le qu'est ce que je peux raisonnablement
faire dans ma position donc oui tu le
fais ma tête mais après c'est sûr que ce
que tu vois livres et bien il faut que
ce soit quand même prudent dire d'un
garde moi je peux pas prouver des choses
je peux pas être certain de ce qui s'est
passé
pitié la réalité comme dans ce cas aussi
il y aurait fallu pour pouvoir trouver
la vérité en gris mais là ça prendrait
une enquête policière sur place au pérou
le stand no games
dans ce podcast eût dit que aussitôt que
tu parlais radio-canada ton projet des
dérives édition fait une deuxième saison
c'est ce dossier là qu'est ce qui t'a
attiré dans
ce cas précis lot de nelson sont
entamées en essonne deschamps et celle
des chaînes qui était qui et qui est
mort pour ceux qui nous écoutent
quiconque une d'elles qui est mort dans
un centre où est ce qu'ils faisaient des
expériences avec la sq qui est une
drogue hallucinogène
très exactement c'est ça moi je
m'intéresse à la santé si je m'intéresse
à la santé d'un angle si je m'intéresse
beaucoup aux pseudo science aux
croyances tio pratique un peu alternatif
dix artistes c'est quelque chose qui me
fascine c'est sûr que quand une histoire
comme ce qui sort dans les médias
mouassa m'accroche instantanément qui
moi je me ramène à cette histoire là je
les ai entendus en fait je les lui dans
les journaux sa sortie en 2010 neuf
postes au mois d'octobre dans la presse
il y avait un article où ça disait un
gosse s'est suicidé ans en se
poignardant lui-même dans le vendre dans
un sauna et aux oscars déjà c'est
horrible je le désire comme tu imagines
suis comme façon de mourir puis après ce
bain dans l'article y évoquer plein
questions en suspens ce genre là on a
essayé de contacter le monde la bonne
donne une version le la police donne une
autre version le apparemment que jodie
jean la famille qui disent on n'a pas su
toute la vérité si c'est toutes les eaux
certains de ces la prémisse d'une
immense histoire puis là après moins
jusqu'aux mains je veux savoir la suite
jamais dessus et c'est ici sa curiosité
scientifique et pis qu'il l'ait ma
curiosité scientifique hippiques et
c'est la première fois que j'entends
parler de l'ayahuasca à ce moment là
personnellement je n'ai jamais entendu
parler de turin et le toutes ces
réponses en fait j obtiens jamais de
réponse puis la bête si ça me trotte
dans ta est finalement pendant longtemps
puis c'est clairement quand j'ai proposé
là l'idée de la saison 1 de dérive
c'était l'histoire de chantal lavigne
qui morte dans un rituel de sudation on
se rappelle en 2011 avait été mis en tue
découverte de la boue du plastique la
tête dans une boîte pendant neuf heures
de tentes c'était horrible j'ai presque
tout le monde au québec le sait ça ça me
trottait noms en tête mais l'histoire de
nelson était juste deux pas en arrière
ces deux histoires l'homme était juste
j'ai peur ça m'obsédait
président à baladou a plus que tu as
failli changer de sujet pas traité ceux
ci m'ont dit si la bonne information sur
seul bah oui parce que au début comme tu
procèdes ces mois de la première chose
que j'ai faite c'est que je me suis même
pas créé par juste par respect pour les
choses j'ai fait contacter des gens de
la famille puis la première réaction de
la famille ça a été de me dire ah écoute
nous le sert et s'enlacent a fait ça
fait deux ans qu'on se posait même pas
deux ans et que leur première action
s'était faite à écoute nous en ce moment
là on était encore dans de la grosse
douleur puis on se sent pas comme
incapable d'en parler faites le mais il
n'était pas fermée à ce que je fasse la
démarche quand même fait que je me suis
dit ben qu'est ce que je fais je le fais
tu en as en impliquant pour la famille
dit faites-le j'ai commencé à chercher
des mines nelson mais j'avais pas de
piste fait le chercher sur sa page
facebook je me sentais un peu marre gens
qui avaient largué en études sont des
gens qui veulent la photo cl avec une
coupe de photos c'est peut-être des amis
proches communiquer avec les autres via
facebook c'est fou qu'on puisse faire
soi même en fait le mot c'est drôle
parce que je discute souvent des 10 avec
mon tronc commun connaîtrait pour
personnes en quête comme ce jeu comme
facebook c'est facebook c'est mon outil
comme moi c'est vraiment comme ça que je
parle là de la vaste majorité de mes
recherches pour trouver du monde des
épices des affaires moi c'est sur
facebook facebook le siffler la
formation puisque on pense c'est que les
gens réalisent pas à quel point il est
l'information là dessus puis après bien
souvent je pense qu'ils tuent comme
exemple que des gens que j'ai retrouvé
le sur facebook l'oxi habite dans un
autre pays puis lyon jamais pensé qu'un
12 au québec à les lire leur petit
commentaire sur un stade où il y aussi
les gens se rendent juste par contre
comme un air de l'information fait avec
moi c'est sauf que j'ai regardé des gens
qui avaient laïcs et les postes de
nelson dans la dernière année avant son
décès je leur ai écrit leurs idées salut
je m'appelle olivier j'essaie de faire
telle chose
beat it suivent avec difool gants blancs
le vraiment si vous n'êtes pas à l'aise
et pas de problème je pour faire de la
il y avait cependant une missionnaire de
maîtrise il était sur le journalisme
littéraire il fallait faire une enquête
sur un artiste québécois puis moi je
voulais un artiste qui me fascine st
jean leloup sur ce que je m'étais dit
impossible de me rendre jusqu'à jean
leloup laitiers comme si comme il
n'existe pas on dirait l'autre puis ma
prof m'avait dit
sophie létourneau on m'avait dit tu le
sais pas
tant que tu le peux demander tant que
pas essayer fait finalement j'avais fait
juste une publication sur facebook drive
by the way s'il ya quelqu'un dans les
520 personnes que je connais qui peut me
diriger vers jean leloup boss vous plaît
écrivez moi flamand et avait plusieurs
personnes qui m'avait écrit puisqu'il en
était ressorti de mon reportage était
plus un genre de deux reportages de moi
qui ai se trouvait jean leloup mettant
le site était plus sûr qu'un reportage
sur jean de luz de plus la démarche vers
le trouver mais au final je m'étais
rendu utile jusqu'à son email
personnelle puis il m'avait répondu un
email c'est comme en mai à gasquet
j'avais essayé puis j'ai bien fait
d'essayer ça a commencé par un pot ce
que tu as fait sur les réseaux sociaux
etc ça exact en raison de dire que tout
cela n'était pas possible avant puis
c'est vrai et c'est moins la main la
community la majorité de ce que je fais
c'est via les réseaux sociaux pour
trouver des pistes des jambes tout ce
qui c'est extraordinaire a pity sur des
rives on a un consultant qui travaillent
avec nous qui est un journaliste lui un
vieux de la vieille le justice avec de
grands le plus grand respect du monde
multi genres il a été rédacteur en chef
jean démission en cas est le parrain
j'espère longtemps et qui travaillent
avec nous comme consultant pour
s'assurer qu'on respecte les normes et
pratiques journalistiques pour vérifier
les choses que j'ai faites juge
s'attaque radio can me laisse pas faire
tout ce que je puis qui vérifie pas fait
lui travaille avec nous lui est vraiment
lotis de la vieille méthode le ti lui
dans le talent je dirais il fouillait
dans des papiers dans les bottins
t'appeler du monde je veux dire c'était
une autre game complètement aujourd'hui
de n'importe qui en théorie peut
s'improviser
genre enquêteurs beaucoup s'improvisent
inquiétant après nous d'être les trois
facteurs
ouais on le fait dans notre vie
personnelle porte sa barbe a vraiment
déçu et même moi je le ferai pas dans
d'autres contextes ya même une
expression en anglais le cheval je vois
mal dire le monde aime essayer d'apaiser
web toulouse je pense là dessus si et
c'est le but et à chelsea c'est tout le
monde décide qui vont comme résoudre des
crimes
parmi eux il y en a de temps en temps
que ça marche ouais bah oui c'est ça il
ya en même temps en tant que ça marche
c'est juste nous on connaît bien et
victoria charlton qt ou buzz de tchouk
rhymes et puis des fois par le fait
qu'elle ait une présence qui parle de
trucs ramener des gens qui écrivent à
elle avec des informations légitimes
concernant un cop 15 x ou y que la
police juste pas eu accès parce que l
allonnes présence de médias sociaux
disent il faut parer la wii ça se
produit effectivement à pourraient avoir
accès à des pistes que d'autres auront
pas après je pense que ce qu'il faut
puis ça va faire un lien ce que je
disais tantôt que moi ça m'a fait
beaucoup plus apprécié le journalisme si
ça peut être deux saisons dérives que je
fais où je dois - si je suis pas
journaliste mais je dois suivre les
mêmes règles que les journalistes qui
appelle les normes et pratiques
journalistiques
ils sont en particulier radio-canada son
grand cheval ils sont très à cheval là
tu le fait qu'ils prennent enfin que tu
fais le bien des enfants que j'ai avec
des découvertes déjà faites chez comme
et j'ai découvert ça c'est malade pions
comme c'est cool mais en projet mais
médecin by adobuzz com pourquoi il faut
que ce soit corroborée par au moins
trois sources il faut qu'il faut qui est
à la fois sage comme je pourrai jamais
corroboré se met par fenêtre proposé
l'excellent hop tu réalises que tu es
comme au shit pour arriver avec un
quelque chose de solide lapidaire
rigoureux afin c'est
s'étoffe c'est effectivement ça me fait
plus appréciés journal
je pense que vous avez vu le film spot
lights pas de l'être dans le fond c'est
l'histoire vraie le petit puis
apparemment c'est ce qu'il me suis fait
dire de ce que j'ai lu c'est quand même
vraiment fidèle à qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour vrai dans l'équipe spotlight
qui ont mis à combien aux jo jours
toute cette histoire de pédophilie dans
l'église bien sûr dans le fond le comme
tu dis là c'est dans les répertoires des
pride appeal qui change de paroisse ou
plus y ont vu un bateau là dedans
médecin s'ils n'ont pas de registre en
ligne ne sont pas sur facebook à
regarder les histoires mais tu imagines
tu le travail énorme hein mais pas de
casse préféré des dernières années ça
s'appelle in the dark la deuxième saison
d'une odeur je le conseille aux gens si
ça les intéresse c'est une grosse
enquête qui un moment donné on en parle
dans le bain bérive non
non je parle d'un autre pas de casque
j'ai bien aimé
mais in the dark saison 2 un moment
donné il ya un épisode en particulier où
ils vont fouiller il trouve un package
on y trouve une pièce kif qui est
condamné le quitta en ruine depuis des
années puis il ya plein de papiers dans
des classeurs puis tout est moisi parce
que lâche pas la pourriture la moins
sûre au poignet là dedans puis il passe
un an essentiellement juste prendre les
papiers puis à tout recopier alors tu
n'as pas ce qui est écrit sur papier le
sas et du journaliste d'enquêté pour moi
que sa demande
c'est surtout dans mon cas je pense
qu'il ya des choses que j'étais capable
je me disais moi ce qui est important
c'est de comprendre comprendre nelson
comprendre sa démarche comprend de plus
largement la démarche des autres
personnes qui vont faire ce puits de
comprendre l'ayahuasca l'univers quand
on lie au score puis après je me suis
pas mis de pression en disant ça à la
fin j'ai pas de réponse définitive ce
qui est arrivé ben c'est correct ça
m'appartient pas de faire ça mais
j'aurais au moins j'aurais donné le plus
de perspectives possibles pour que les
gens puissent se faire une idée après
dix mois je me suis quand on a dû
discuter une fois pitt m'avait dit c'est
un peu plus grands fans de poker de tous
crins en général parce que souvent ça va
tirer des hypothèses un peu tiré par les
cheveux ou s'est-il ça va essayer de
faire une version officielle mais le on
amène de nouvelles hypothèses pour mais
sans doute puisque finalement c'est
comme ça flirte un peu avec eux le
complète ici quasiment le tir mais
mettons dans ton podcast
il ya une version officielle que tu mets
en doute ou si c'est dans le fond on ne
peut séparer les différents c'est quoi
si tu la rigueur qu'à quelqu'un qu'on
fait la recherche après ou ben en fait
dans le code nelson n'y avait pas
vraiment de version officielle c'est
mieux pour moi et u11 arpenté la rue de
la pie c'était voici ce qu'on sait pour
le moment de façon provisoire
détails à suivre puis au dessus puis la
seule version en guillemette officielle
qu'on avait c'était les légendes ou
chantaient le propriétaire du centre la
baule où l'incidence des produits qui
disait faites dans pour propos presque
un peu de contexte aux jeunes elsom ce
qu'on croyait s'excite qui avait pris de
l'ayahuasca donc la boisson
hallucinogènes pis que ça l'aurait
peut-être poussé à s'enlever la vie
mais le propriétaire chanter disait non
non non il n'y a pas but d'ailleurs à ce
qu'à l'avenir rien d'ailleurs ce cas là
dedans y en avait pas dans son sens y
avait rien ok tu vraiment une version
officielle ces jeux on s'entend incendie
wasquehal application sur facebook lewis
est en plein milieu de la jungle
amazonienne on n'est pas du tout la même
réalité effectivement quand je veux
protéger sa réputation exacte avec moi
quand je dis que de douter de la version
officielle ces genres maintenant imagine
qu'il ya toute une enquête complète de
police puis qu'après ce que tu dis moi
je fais pas confiance à lenquête de
police complète sur une chose dans ce
cas aussi il ne put bay en avait pas eu
en apparence bien après avoir fouillé
j'ai toujours pas l'impression qu'on a
eu une je pense que c'est peut-être sur
la distinction une des choses dans le
podcast qui moi m'a vraiment frappé
c'est une des questions à laquelle
d'areva à la fin du podcast puisque
c'est toute la question autour
de la décriminalisation des drogues de
l'accompagnement
la compagne d'avoir un meilleur
accompagnement dans ces deux règles
parce que parce qu'ils étaient le lot
fameux war on drugs que tu parles
pendant le podcast a été une énorme a
formé à nice tandis que les
gouvernements ont dépensé des milliards
de dollars pour essayer de lutter contre
un espèce d'ennemis invisible qui était
finalement invincible jamais de la vie
ça allait pouvoir on allait pouvoir
vendre sur le tire et j'écoutais narcose
justement le tpiy par la cauquenne du la
cocaïne dans le fond le sais tu en
prends une fois puisque ça fait quinze
minutes plus tard tu veux à reprendre
encore aucune façon dont puisse battre
seul été et puis après ça tout l'idée de
la décriminalisation
devient on dirait la seule manière de
grands la seule manière de vraiment
contrôler est-ce que quelques élites a
pa ta position parce que je sais que je
pose la question du volume et qu'est ce
tu en penses dans le fond à la lumière
de toute cette histoire là où est ce
qu'il ya des gens juste même quand tu
vois avant la langue ou camper car la
petite rappelle le guide de varenne val
david val david val alain celle au bord
du gave hal david qui lui vend fait ici
métier encore dans des contextes sont un
peu chez dit
c'est qu'est ce que tu en penses dans le
fond maintenant tous la même opinion qu
à la fin du bail vraiment n'ont vraiment
pas passer ce qui est le fun de faire
une démarche comme ça c'est tout
confronte un peu à tes préjugés ou à tes
convictions puis moi c'était quelque
chose que je voulais faire moi j'ai
parti le bal à dos que je le dis au tout
début le dépanneur chose que je dis
c'est garder moi j'en ai jamais consommé
de ma vie des droits créatifs parce que
ça me fait peur je ne pars viscéral de
touche je ne sais pas d'où ça vient
c'est comme ça puis j'ai aussi grandi
comme beaucoup de gens avec l'idée que
la drogue c'est mal
que si tu prend de la drogue quand tu es
jeune comme je peux mains jointes ça va
nous mener vers les drogues dures comme
citoyenne le team salat licher dire ça
mais c'est quand même c'est dans ce
concept son héroïne
je peux si tu veux qu'ils ont déçu ou
non mais dans leur case à midi par
tamara territoire a dit c'est la
dernière chose qu'on veut c'est que
notre enfant bien de la drogue tactile
qui comprend d'où tu viens aussi que tu
t'es des parents si c'est pas un petit
joint ce programme fait rien faut pas
qu'il faut que les enfants oui et on
peut encore plus considéré que nos
parents ont pas mal tout déjà pris de la
drogue puis pas juste des joints le
meilleur pas mal tout déjà fait j ai
décidé d en faire de même dans les
années hippies et l'autre etc ces
parents là après que nous ont appris à
nous autres de nos générations georges
paillas drogue ce qui est toujours un
peu spécial c'est de penser à ce fait
moi je partis avec tout ce bagage le si
on retire jeu c'est probablement mon
bagage d'éducation des préjugés des
affaires cette peur là que j'avais qui
au fil de la série un moment donné moi
je m'expose à des experts et puis des
gens qui me disent at un peu le pas sans
nous la communauté des experts en
toxicomanies notre position là dessus
c'est que la criminalisation des drogues
beaucoup de désavantages et hop
peut-être même plus de désavantages que
d'inconvénients
oui exactement exactement c'est se
piloter comme battant le russe comme
juste bizarre pl après tu te rends
compte que non que c'est une idée qui
est largement proposée puis l'idée
derrière ça c'est que quand tu
criminalise bien apprécié les gens vont
faire pareil c'est ça les 800 que c'est
interdit les drogues parfait moment de
vendre le monde quand le coup d'enfants
ils vont en faire c'est un final que ça
n'a jamais fonctionné non plus la
prohibition de l'alcool ça a été thaerim
parce qu'ils y ont fait ils ont interdit
l'alcool qu'est ce que les gens en fait
ils ont créé des bars clandestins est en
fait de l'alcool dans des alambics cet
alcool a été excessivement dangereux
quand tu fais ça de manière artisanale
c'est entre avec de l'alcool frelaté qui
va voir du méthanol des fois de dingue
des produits de contamination qui vont
prendre avec jo c'était horrible fait
qu'un place que ce qui en fait ils ont
fini par isabelle l'alcool on vole on va
lui mettre légal avec des contrôles
trois pilotes par rapport aux drogues en
ce moment mais il ya beaucoup de pays
dans le monde incluant le canada qui
seulement on devrait tout faire pour les
autres drogues aussi parce que on a beau
interdire la cocaïne le 6 le seul
héroïne wever les psychédéliques mais le
monde en font pareil meilhan fond dans
rue que c'est acheter dans des labos
clandestins que
presque tout le temps ce que les gens
pensent consommer c'est pas toi vraiment
ce qui est à l'intérieur c'est ce que
les études démontrent la commandite
disais pourquoi ce qu on enlève pour
décriminaliser pour ça puisqu'on me
posent certains contrôles on se rappelle
du sepa de dire prenez ans pourrait vous
pénaliser fait que c'est une autre
approche qui s'appelle la réduction des
méfaits donc d'accepter que les gens
vont en faire mais de leur permettre
d'en faire avec une sécurité et une
détresse qui laissait existons épaules
tu es le monde sont pas liées à la danse
et au milieu de la rue par tous les
genres et on n'est pas une société de
films de potes pour autant les gens qui
ont consommé en consomment encore de
manière plus encadré oui pillon l'option
parce qu'on s'entend le des gens ils
peuvent encore aller chercher leurs
dealers qui ont fait pousser chez eux le
jeu des lions encore cette option là
mais en même temps il peut aussi se dire
ben non je vois aller en chercher à
excuser ces ihu c'est un produit qui a
été contrôlée pied et c'est europe qui
ça peut apporter une certaine sortait
avec le cannabis peut-être que c'est
plus acceptée socialement mais compensée
comme les substances hallucinogènes
comme le lsd des blindes gens qui ont
envie de dire et moi une fois dans ma
vie j'ai envie de faire un trip délaisse
des mails à la journée ou du club des
ltte le gouda little cherche et on a les
yeux rivés sur les chercher où
exactement l'attitude en bas dans une
ruelle sombre qui
se regarde un go qui est leur petit
pécule d'étudier lsd il vient d'où son
lsd puis dans le balade au jeu par là
une experte de elle a travaillé sur la
rue dans les festivals et cetera
toxicomanie pis a m'a dit ça existe plus
du lsd mais non ça n'existe plus on a pu
c'est tout et des produits de des
variantes en fait c'est des choses qui
appelle du lsd mais en fait c'est
d'autre à faire vraiment souvent
dangereuses n'a rien à voir du ls
direction décriminaliser potentiellement
qu'on pourrait assurer un certain
contrôle de qualité puis en plus si t'as
vu ta tout ça je sais pas si c'est la
même experte qui tu parles mais qui fait
la liste fait la liste des drogues sont
le plus nuisible pour la société puisque
le numéro un bain en eau si l'alcool les
derniers en bourse
ça c'est moi qui ai trouvé ça en fait
mais c'est quelqu'un qui m'en avait déjà
parlé mais je me suis pas qu'il m'en
avait parlé mais c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai parlé dans la recherche qui me dit
souvent les gens savaient plus élevé que
les psychédéliques sedan les drogues les
qui on creuse le moindre dommage sa
société proche du feu moi je penserais
pas honnêtement finalement ça a été
publié en 2019 dans le journal de
lanceurs qui comme une des plus grosses
lundi périodiques scientifiques les plus
réputés dans le monde qui est une grosse
analysions garder c'est quoi les
dommages causés sur la société par
différentes drogues effectivement les
psychédéliques sont en bas de la liste
pourquoi parce que presque personne en
consomme c'est marginal puis deux baies
leur potentiel d'abus et pas très élevé
c'est quand même tu n'y a pas de temps
d'effets secondaires s'ils sont utilisés
intelligemment si peu plus ou moins
actifs les moins c'est pas super
addictif pour des raisons qui sont
reliés à leur pharmacologie mais à côté
de ça le tabac par exemple le stand
renault lombardi
les dommages causés par l'est sur la
société par le tableau son bistrot
nomique l'alcool ou si l'alcool
potentiel de dépendance super élevée
banalisation extrême dans presque tous
les pays du monde je veux dire les
dommages que sa fille sur le corps sont
absolument atroces le tir quand on
consomme trop fait que les contrôles se
ramène les choses différemment c'est
vrai on n'a pas des psychedelic mais
pendant ce temps le l'alcoolique sommes
vingt fois pays on envoie des annonces à
tva toutes les deux annoncé une annonce
d'alcool est totalement tiré alors que
si on met donc maintenant qu'on légalise
de même atteint le pic blanc qui
criminalise le lundi 2 mai matin je
m'excuse le mispo à 50% la population
qui va le faire du lsd le pape ne sait
si c'est très marginal il des raisons
historiques pourquoi met on les laisse
dit à ma patrie pts à part estimé lesnar
non mauvaise réputation qui sont sont
interdits vert social kalou - dans le
fond j'ai parlé à une historienne
clinique et qui est spécialisée dans ces
questions là donc tout ce qui t'as beau
alcool et ses pièces comme expliqué
c'est que
quand car en fait dans les années 60 70
ok c'est le moment les années hippies
les années de la contre culture à un
moment donné les drogues circuler
librement le site allait dans un
festival de musique comme si tu allais
rocher à gauche maintenant qui tout le
monde se passer de la drogue c'est
peut-être comme ça ceci étant dit je ne
vois pas beaucoup dans les festivals
fait que c'est être de même en ce moment
mais
il a un
style c'est des gros festivals et des
petits festivals de danse fort elle qui
est à peu près 1000 2000 personnes ou
100% du monde je me suis fait dire que
100% du monde et julie levac jo c'est
juste une réalité mais à l'époque s'il
n'y avait pas de loi avec dans le fond
le monde faisait ce qu'il voulait
puis le verre là au début des années
soixante dix millions interdit ce c'est
sûr que quand tu en as tu dis ben oui
c'est sûr je voulais protéger les gens
voulaient protéger la santé des gens
mais la réalité c'est qu'il y avait
aussi une des inquiétudes purement
politique et idéologique derrière ça
parce qu'à l'époque faut comprendre que
le mouvement psychédélique était vu
comme un mouvement de renversement delà
des dictats de la société de
renversement des ddd hiérarchie sociale
de renverser le gouvernement même
jusqu'à un certain point c'était sur la
culture des psychedelic stay on va
toutefois qu'il en va tout scrap est ce
qu'on va faire un monde meilleur
gouvernement sur leurs tentes et paul
fait que c'est sûr que c'est à ce moment
là qu'ils ont interdit les
psychédéliques oui pour protéger les
populations mais aussi à cause d'une
inquiétudes sous jacentes qui était bien
on veut pour 6 que la sculpture la crise
tu as aussi avait été dangereuse me
voyais ça comme super subversif qui
avait pas que ça amène à une certaine
révolution sociale c'est comme ça que
l'historienne l'expliquent dans mon mal
à dos qu'il a apprécié le style légal
sûr que le problème ce cas précis et
plein d'autres drogues son entrée sur le
marché qui était bien pire si la cocaïne
toutes les drogues de synthèse et c'est
heureux
c'est n'importe quoi qu'il peut être
fait dans des langues dans des labos
clandestins loti fixe après des choses
comme le sas après des choses comme
l'ecstasy mais ça pourrait tout c'est du
cristal mère de ses deux enfants mangent
pas un spécialiste d'eads règle mais
virtuellement n'importe quoi qui peut
faire dans un labo un nom officiel c'est
enfin que cinq encore le tiens on
interdit les piquer des candidats c'est
bien trop subversif mais à côté de ce
seuil il ya des drogues qui inondent le
marché qui sont comme tellement pire
pour plein de raisons là dessus et la
cocaïne l'héroïne
pilot bay la crise ici on n'a qu'à
penser à la crise des opiacés convient
en amérique du nord depuis j'ai pas une
couple d'années la chaussée des
médicaments d'ordonnancé le concret
encore les dédommage bien plus grand que
ce que les psychédéliques aurait fait
puis j'avais parlé aussi l'été dernier
que
une petite carotte qui est un ami d'ami
puis qui a un de ses amis créent de la
recherche justement sur les
psychédéliques la thérapie mais ton
petit kit cm expliqué aussi que en
recherche avait été un petit peu
tablettes et les recherches jean luc est
délicat à cause justement de cette
association le à ce mouvement le système
mal vue puis finalement il d'autres
types de drogues avait eu beaucoup plus
de recherches pris beaucoup de méthode
mais de médicamentation qui était faite
avec six molécules le plus calé
puisqu'il exécute en moins et puis je
pense qu'il ya deux raisons pour cela
première raison c'est qu'il mais les
drogues étaient illégales fait que c'est
sûr que d'étudier une substance illégale
des jeux c'est compliqué parce que comme
chercheurs et chercheuses il faut que tu
demandes des exemptions ou du
gouvernement puis mine de rien c'est
très très difficile ces gens de même
c'est un centre de recherche réputé pis
tout le dire je vois faire des études
avec du lsd ou d'affaires et bonne
chance c'est vraiment compliqué fait
qu'ils avaient déjà toutes ces obstacles
réglementaires l'autre problème ici
c'est que dans les années justement 62
50 60 il ya eu pas mal de la recherche
avait déjà commencé là sur les
psychédéliques qu'il prenne ce qui a
beaucoup de chercheurs de cette époque
là qu'ils sont devenus comment dire et
on partie des recherches que bébé de la
leur qui après les y ont pris une espèce
de dérape total pseudo scientifiques
sont devenus des ambassadeurs du likoud
sont devenus des gourous du
psychédélique leurs recherches qui sont
devenus non scientifique c'était
n'importe quoi lost est rendu ça amène
pourquoi se souhaite lui
honnêtement je ne sais pas si je peux
pas parler pour ces individus là mais je
pense que c'était en fait
c'est pas différent de n'importe quoi si
je regarde moi le récemment d'un
journaleux joies du monde qui par
l'audition des experts en nutrition puis
que l'oeil commence à me dire à me
vanter les vertus des agrumes c'est quoi
la différence entre les deux sont
devenus aussi des évangélistes des
fruits là je veux dire c'est juste que
des fruits de lsd c'est différent mais
est ce que l'on commencé à étudier la
nutrition puis on finit en étant des
évangélistes des agrumes qui oppriment
dérape pareil demain jeudi je pense que
quand tu fais de la recherche
il ya toujours le risque que tu
sois tellement passionné par des travaux
comme en es-tu finissent par perdre ton
esprit critique que celui qu'on m'a tbm
donc oui si c'est pour ça que ce jeu est
pressenti c'est quelque chose dont on
parle souvent l'on doit être tanné de
montagne au sommet c'est une éducation
et une formation scientifique ça donne
pas automatiquement les outils d'esprit
critique tu sais que tu peux commencer
ta carrière en faisant des super bonne
recherche presse à prendre une dérape il
leur reste de ta carrière c'est
n'importe quoi le domaine et
psychédélique il ya beaucoup de gens
qu'on entend loti si vous lisez sur les
pionniers des psychedelic c'est des gens
qui ont fait des choses très importantes
au début de leur carrière une chance
qu'ils ont fait mais sur quatre qui ont
fait après c'est n'importe quoi et que
je pense qu'à un moment donné ça a donné
mauvaise réputation pour répondre à ta
question parce qu'on a dit d'argane le
phénomène les chercheurs et
psychédélique siphon c'est un peu
n'importe quoi c'est de la pseudo
science mais encore là tout est une
question de contexte parce que ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui comme recherche c'est
beaucoup plus sérieux et en général il
ya moins de ces espèces de tournures le
blizzard quoique des foyers en eau mais
c'est moins be put mettons à la lumière
des informations qu'on a aujourd'hui
trouve suc et mettons en psychiatrie ça
peut être intéressant d'utiliser
puisqu'il est dit que ton
nom est trop tôt pour se prononcer il se
paye ça dira pourquoi c'est parce que
c'est sûr que
une chose qui est une chose qui est
plate puis en même temps je sais même
pour toutes le ans par rapport à la
santé le mais si tu vas sur internet et
sully sur est ce que les psychédéliques
peuvent aider pour la santé mentale 99%
que tu vas aller aussi c'est un remède
miracle bon c'est difficile de se faire
une opinion et l'air est là dessus quand
tu regarde vraiment dans les études qui
ont été faites le ce qui a vraiment du
potentiel en ce moment c'est la
psychothérapie a suscité avec des
psychedelic le mob ce côté rapide il
faut que soit leur support je prends des
psychedelic chez nous puis je vais mieux
de sa misère au paint ball sport c'est
je fais une psychothérapie sûr et on
parle généralement de 12 ce qu'ils font
dans les protocoles d'étude de ce qu'ils
vont prendre une personne ils leur font
faire deux séances de psychothérapie
avec un psychologue spécialisé puis dans
trois de ces séances là à intervalles
réguliers ils vont leur faire prendre
puisque délictuelle pendant trois quatre
heures la personne à vis quelque chose à
vis des leurs alors un regard différent
sur ses émotions de quoi elle a des
souvenirs qui reviennent quelques oh
mince j'ai pas pensé à ça depuis des
années le thérapeute est à côté il ya
une offre un accompagnement you fin une
sécurité la prépa plan sciences où tu
prends pas de risques et des litiges
avec le thérapeute l'homme année par
près avec douze séances trois de ces
séances au lieu-dit psychédélique seul
sait ce qui est étudiée en ce moment sur
sa du potentiel ça à du vrai potentiel
très prometteur pour traiter des
traumatismes certain type de dépression
des enfants que déjà le ça fait des
années qu'ils traînent sopi qui sont pas
capables sans assortir là c'est très
prometteur bon certes on est loin de
dire je vois juste si je vous dis pas je
prédis champions magique je vais aller
mieux le son on est vraiment vraiment
paul
le problème qui jaillit le plus je
trouve dans dans toute ta recherche
autour de la world cup puisque de nelson
en particulier
c'est on dirait que toutes les personnes
du club cyclone haute à qui tu parles du
psychiatre le temps ouais les voyageurs
d'un esprit où toutes les psycho note à
qui tu parles
disent avoir commencé un cheminement un
fameux cheminement qui existe quelque
part depuis ce cheminement là
on sais pas vers quoi exactement on sait
pas et par 2 où on sait pas si c'est
croit-il beaucoup de monde l'entrevue
qui disent qu'ils ont
qui ont vu qu'ils voient maintenant la
vie différemment puis que ça les a aidés
mais comme on parlait je savais juste
avant de venir ici on dirait qu'à chaque
fois que quelqu'un dit que ça l'a aidé
on dirait qu'ils vont pas mieux jamais
mieux pis c'est quoi ce cheminement loeb
cette ouverture vers une autre vision du
monde qui se posent et aider mais qu'au
final fait juste que
ça peut être sa peine commenté dans le
fond on le sait parce que pas
d'encadrement pour diriger après cela la
lecture ou le déblocage de ces
émotions-là puis c'est comme on dit que
c'est flou pour moi c'est quoi le
cheminement tirs qu'on l'entend aussi
des fois maintenant mettons ces
restitutions des gens qui ont d éveil
spirituel tuer mais c'est tellement
pas concret qui sont pas grave non plus
le mettre en mots puis on parle avons
une vision du monde tellement différent
d'avant sexy c'est quoi tout entend dire
quoi maintenant comme quant aux
observations de tout ces gens là qui te
parle et qui ont commencé leur
cheminement méthode si je comprends
totalement ta confusion parce que si
effectivement je pense difficile de
comprendre quand tu le vis pas ses
jumeaux début ce que je me suis dit si
je vais parler au maximum de jean-pierre
dans le bain et la douche on fait par
les plus jeunes j'ai pas la bête le
domaine que ce il y en a qui m'ont dit
je vais te parler juste domaine mais il
n'est pas question que tu mettes dans un
podcast j'ai fait de farine j'ai pas là
plein plein plein plein de monde qui
avaient des cheminements comme ceux
envers des disques et des bons première
chose qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
c'est pas tout le monde que les mêmes
buts et il y en a qui veulent juste
ripper envoyant des formes géométriques
dans
mais c'est parfait il y en a qui sont
dans une démarche de croissance
personnelle slash spiritualité ça c'est
sûr que c'est un fourre tout où l'on
s'entend là ça peut vouloir dire tout et
n'importe quoi c'est peu des gens qui
disent - les psychédéliques
ça m'a fait comprendre des choses sur
moi-même que je comprenais pas avant
enfin une chose correcte peut-être qu'il
y aurait pu faire autre chose j'aurais
pu aller faire du travail humanitaire en
afrique qu'il y aurait aussi découvrir
de quoi sur un même séjour je pense que
pour une seule façon envie d'arriver à
des réponses ou et c'est heureux qu'ils
apprennent toutes sortes de gens qui
sont en quête de bien-être au niveau de
la santé mentale - ce que j'ai remarqué
c'est que souvent
souvent que beaucoup de gens à qui j'ai
parlé mais la raison principale qui ne
citait pas nécessairement la raison
principale de ce n'est pas
nécessairement la seule raison je donne
un exemple je parle en fait dans le bal
à dos qui me dit moi je fume 400%
spirituel mais en parler avec elle de
fil en aiguille la a fini par me dire on
hamm est moins choquant mais j'ai un
tempérament très dépressif j'ai fait une
dépression j'ai fait des dépressions
plus jeune j'ai déjà vécu des visas but
dans ma vie tout soit puis finalement
c'est plus de la guérison de problèmes
psychologiques type de traumatisme fait
qu elle elle définit comme une
expérience commune une démarche
spirituelle
mais en réalité à le dire à le dip allen
détresse psychologique profond mais
est-ce que ça l'avait aidé ce elle parce
que moi si ses joueurs c'est comme en
direct au l'on sait du monde qui ont des
trois mois qu'ils veulent régler les
affaires puis en direct aux lentilles de
nelson c'est le meilleur exemple celle
ci il parle de ces trois mois mais on
dirait qu'à chaque fois qu'il fait un
triple derrière ou à ce chaos qui en
aurait fait la laci flou sur le nombre
pi le campus commun mais on dirait que
ça va jamais mieux le nom c'est que la
seconde qui en a fait la première fois
ça a juste été moins bien payé tu es
dans une on dirait qu'il cherchait une
quête d'amélioration de soi mais que
ouais qu'au final c'est est jamais mieux
exactement qui cédant dans les pièces
que je parlais la psychothérapie un
système des pistolets l'économie bon
seuil des études qu'on fait là dessus
pour n'est capable de comparer
maintenant si tu fais juste une
psychothérapie normal versus une
psychothérapie qu'un psychédélique pour
certains types de problèmes voici la
belle avantage pics était en panne et
capable de démontrer que c'est un effet
qui a tout un encadrement
par des professionnels ce qui est
l'agent zéro ou une psychologue etc des
psychiatres la dengue s'est développé à
la fin la personne oui c'est vrai
qu'elle va mieux c'est sûr que quand tu
pars ça pis tu fais ça pour toi même le
comment tu fais pour mesurer si tu vaux
mieux tiens c'est facile de se raconter
je vais mieux mais moi la plupart des
gens que j'ai rappelé à qui j'ai parlé
ça faisait longtemps qu'ils prenaient
des psychedelic qui était encore dans
une détresse assez importante et le ceo
moi j'ai de la peine parce que je me dis
je mets pas ça sur leur dos à eux dans
un sens ces personnes là il semble
dépourvu be ils n'ont pas personne pour
les accompagner là dedans dans un monde
idéal il y aurait des gens pour les
accompagner il y aurait de
l'accompagnement professionnel mais en
même temps c'est illégal ouais ouais
même moi comme pharmacien le quelqu'un
vient me voir et me dit j'aimerais ça
que tu suives litige serait pas soit
parce que je me sens pas outillée puis
je me sens pas assez exprimé qui me
diraient et moi je fais une grosse
grosse des marchés du lsd des champions
magique je me suis souvent compagne là
dedans j'ai pas le droit de faire ça
si je pense que je comprends ce que tu
veux dans le sens moi je moi j'ai
l'impression que quand les gens font
alors manière j'ai pas l'impression que
ça va nécessairement toujours les aider
autant qu'ils croient ce qui manque à
mon avis c'est vraiment un iman qu'un
encadrement professionnel par un
accompagnement ça c'est pas toujours
passé mois à l'écouté du podcast c'est
ce que je trouve qu'ils effectueraient
le plus peur c'est bien plus
le fanatisme qui le côté religieux taux
de tout ce que la substance est le même
je trouve le
sais parce que je n'ai preppy l'un d'eux
puis aussi les l'industrie qui tourne
autour de ce plu fait que ce soit ce jeu
ne m'a pas encadré que ce soit dans des
contextes
vraiment vraiment
vraiment discutable et et puis le côté
c'est sur le côté
religieux de je veux trouver des
réponses là dedans d'autres comme les
espèce de quête spirituelle mais qui
devient
celui qui devient qui prend toute la
place oui pis je les aime en aidant la
radio il ya un terme qui a été proposé
pour ce qu'ils appellent le
contournement spirituel c'est trop bas
est passé en anglais si ces approches un
thème qui définit des pratiques qui les
pratiquent abuse pis rituel
croix est là pour nous faire avancer
dans la vie mais qu'en fait deviennent
une forme des vêtements se demande si tu
passes par la spiritualité mais
finalement tu trouves à éviter de
traiter en profondeur des réelles
souffrances des vrais ta vraie détresse
je trouve que l'ayahuasca autant je
pense que c'est important d'avoir une
vision nuancée mais je suis d'accord
avec ce que tu dis parce que ce que tu
disais lier au score tant que tel on
n'arrête pas de dire mon dieu que c'est
dangereux l'ayahuasca si au final des
incidents graves a parlé parce qu'elle
n'a pas eu le temps que met tout le
contexte qui autour que les gens vont
dans ce sens là ils seront 10 rebonds
l'autre des démons à l'intérieur de toi
le tout ce qui va mal dans ta vie ne
sais pas ce que tu as des entités
maléfiques dans toi qui ont pris
possession de toi et qui te malmène le
faut que tu purifie souvent ils vont
trouver des traumatismes en plus bondir
toilettes un trauma à cause d'une vie
antérieure que des véhicules des enfants
là on est dans un contexte religieux
créer des problèmes prend ensuite garder
le personnel engrenage on est dans un
contexte d'endoctrinement accès puis un
an et je parle à un expert qui dit moins
je pourrai être à l'aise avec ce cet
environnement là si le lait le contexte
c'était et des nuances et celle ci était
riche et nuancé
il ne l'est pas c'est la bosse et du
tout au rien le site arrive le pit et
comment tu vas pas bien parfait lier à
ce que votre guérir ok et moi je suis le
chef spirituel tout ce que je dis est
vrai c'est pour ça qu'on voit tout les
problèmes qui en ce moment par rapport à
lier au scot tous les problèmes viennent
de cette espèce de d'image le hyper
romance et idéalisée de des
hallucinogènes de l'iowa ce code du
chaman comme possédant une vérité que tu
peux pas questionner et puis si je te
dis que tu as des démons ddd dit roman
de vie antérieure mais c'est la réalité
qui est maintenant faut que tu fasses de
quoi par rapport à ce même inversement
si tu te dis que des dons prends ma
prend la parole pour le vrai et puis
c'est important d'investir dans tes dont
fait que deux mois 5000 pièces de plus
pour travailler comme un fou encore -
nelson ça j'ai pas trouvé de piste ne
sommes pas là dessus mais non j'ai
l'impression que c'est ce qui lui est
arrivé parce que des gens qui lui disait
à toi le taux vraiment un don il ya
quelqu'un qui avait dit qu'il voyait un
chaman en lui qui lui et c'était juste
un gars passionné il était intéressé par
ce biais voulu pousser ses
apprentissages le point possible
banco mais effectivement youtube de
renforcement dans cet univers le pin up
beaucoup de tirs il ya pas beaucoup d
acteurs mettent en doute en fait dans
une démarche comme ça c'est la réalité
puis heureusement qui en attire des gens
à qui je parle baldocchi dix mois j'en
ai fait une démarche des scop et
amandine j'ai mis les briques givry
c'est quoi la tête en ce moment je
devrais arrêter ça peut prendre un
moment pour décanter ce que j'ai une vie
puis on verra après ce séjour en enfer
puis souhait que j'ai parlé sont adonnés
canon parfaite après ces puits ont
peut-être fait main ok peut-être que
l'os j'ai essayé ça c'est cool mais
après peut-être jamais besoin maintenant
sont ailleurs
parce que entre que comment les gens en
parlent dans ton bardot passé pour ses
potes et mot plomb on se pol pot balade
au long ballon c'est
la façon que les gens parlent
moi j'ai aucun n'a envie d'en faire non
mais de la façon que les clés gens qui
parce que moi j'ai moi j'ai un ami à moi
qui en a déjà fait un nom qui est allé à
tous leurs maux mexique pour faire
points puis lui en parle super
positivement de l'expérience comme en
saluant des enfants avec d'imaginer que
ceux ci le cas sûrement pour pour des
gens mais métier juste mesure une fois
beat vos mails de base pour rendre
malade c'est la pirouette c'est fait
c'est fait c'est sûr que si il ya une
possibilité de faire un batterie puis
que l'essence même du truc c'est de vos
mains écrit oui parce que les os
castanet meetic faut le mentionner le
sac créé des vomissements assez violent
a chez la plupart des gens ça c'est pour
moi c'est de juin affaire qui d'utiliser
une semaine de vacances
écoute moi non plus qui je le dis aux
des partis au début du premier épisode
j'étais moi je comprends pas les gens
qui vont faire ça honnêtement la fin de
ma démarche je comprends toujours pas
les gens pour faire sauter je pense que
je comprends plus leur détresse je
comprends un peu plus ce qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent faire avec ce lord et
leur désir ou leur motivation ou c ou
peut-être un peu plus qui vont chercher
là dedans aussi est-ce que je
conseillerai des gens d'aller faire soit
personnellement non
mais il reste que les gens vont en faire
pareil puis en amour qui pour eux ça a
du sens de faire simple je pense qu'il
faut respecter ça mais je suis d'accord
avec toi que
moi je m'imaginais justement ali dans
une enfant que je vous mettais déjà déjà
le d'aller en place que je vais vomir à
répétition pu convenir lettre est en
train de nettoyer des énergies négatives
comme je m'excuse mais non là c'est
juste que mon estomac mallet fo king est
et puis j'aime pas ça qui fait juste de
vider le contenu le dis moi que je meure
vie de mes énergies négatives ces
puits après sathit hallucine pendant des
heures les pilotes étaient avec du monde
que tu connais pas moi ça n'est pas
clairement les limites quand ça monte à
quel point ce que des gens pour qui
c'est complètement autre chose moi ça
m'a fasciné le tiche par là une fille
dans le premier épisode et 6ème landry
en fait la comédienne bien dit c'est à
dire jeu dans le fond de la jungle avec
un homme que je connais pas oui je
pilote pendant quatre à six ajout est
reparti no way moi je m'excuse mais je
vois pas d'imaginer cela
fait déjà mais au niveau de
simple surtout quand tu fais un peu de
recherche bien tout en effet beaucoup
mais quand tu tombes là dedans puis que
tu apprends le nombre d'abus sexuels
d'abus physiques auraient eu lieu dans
des trucs de même quand les gens sont
dans leurs situations les plus
vulnérables plus tu fais juste penser à
peut-être une fille sans votre seul dans
le fin fond de la jungle avec un champ
avec un chaman
d'enfoncer encore mais encore là mais
c'est con si oui les vomissements mais
on sait vraiment plus le contexte encore
une fois tu sais moi c'est la raison
pour laquelle je dirais pas
principalement c'est justement à cause
précédent dans le fin fond de la jungle
qui arrive de quoi si une urgence va pas
de soi un topo du site avec quelqu'un
que tu sais pas où sont ces
charmantes mais finalement c'est que
vraiment cette attitude s'il y avait un
charme mettons à verdun où est ce qu'ils
peuvent des ambulanciers sur place la
sécurité et puis le celtix fourneaux
pour faire ce
récréative mmm et ont été mes puis même
là peut-être que ça sera peut-être que
trop peu le coup de faire ça non plus
même si c'était en pleine sécurité et
tiges aux organes ou des groupes qui en
font légalement ici au québec qui
sait si c'est légal ya un certain
encadrement moi j'ai pas plus le gouda
l'enfer c'est pas mon truc mais moi je
pense que c'est que la petite tu dis moi
je pense aussi plus ce contexte tu dis
je pense que c'est plus comme l'est la
cité
honnêtement c'est toutes ces réponses
qui c'est bien plus que ça aussi parce
que tu es honnêtement moi je trouve que
c'est important de sensibiliser à comme
moi c'est là que je recommanderais
jamais à des jeunes allaient faire cela
à l'étranger aux impôts pire ou des
places comme ça pour un paquet de
raisons intentionnés le contexte deux
baies les risques pour la santé puis 3
ou 6 loti je pense que j'en parle dans
le baladeur et thomas celle des abus
sexuels mais plein d'enfants et attiser
la base d'une industrie l'oni qui s'est
accaparé des des traditions autochtones
légitime qu'ils ont un peu voler aux
gens locaux que maintenant c'est des
occidentaux qui vont leur maintenant les
lits les chamans ne veut plus s'occuper
des populations locales fait qu'ils vont
tout donner ce pour la première personne
qui veut leur faire de l'argent et ont
modifié leurs pratiques pour fêter avec
ce que les occidentaux qui ont plein
d'argent veulent
si il ya plein de choses qu'on place
juste purement éthique c'est très
malsain ce j'en ai pas parlé dans balado
pascal mani de telles limites de ce que
tu peux dire aussi mais au point au plan
environnemental ou si il ya une limite
tous à quel point ce que tu peu comme
aller récolter tout six à ces plantes le
liliane et s'était relancé en quantité
limitée en vain ça commence à être un
enjeu sérieusement fait que plus arrêtés
dangereux puis vont mettre n'importe
quoi dans dans leur préparation
exactement exactement parce que la
minute parce que la lier aux ischios
précis à plusieurs plantes que tu peux
utiliser pour faire se met à minutes que
te plus acide de plantes pour faire
l'iowa scott barnes qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire ils vont aller mettre d'autres
plantes qui ont aussi des propriétés
hallucinogènes mais qui sont encore plus
dangereuses gens mentionne quelques-unes
dans le bal à dole des choses comme le
taux et où les brunes félicia que tu te
montres sont membres devrait elle avoir
sur le fait que fait qu en jeu éthique
enjeux de santé en jeu justement de
santé mentale spiritualité
endoctrinement moi je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de raisons il faut que
quelqu'un qui prend conscience du truc
qui me quelqu'un qui écoute mon baladeur
qui a fait une septembre à l'enfer
philippines c'est sûr que je suis
surpris mais ce n'était pas intentionnel
de m'apporter dans le sens où je sais
les gens veulent en faire pareil ce
correct mais au moins on sort il
mesurera un peu plus à quoi à couy
participants et mettons le justement le
témoignage des flandres in si elle
allait leur a dit pour
après abraham avant de se lancer dans
tes dents telli point pi dessus ça aussi
que tu sais
c'est aussi piteusement récréatif lüthi
le fait qu'à la lte ces drogues c'est
pas pour tes a parlé de trauma pas parlé
une honte et de blessures marteau qui
même qu'adil inverse a dit si tu es
quelqu'un d'anxieux c'était quelqu'un
provopoulos rebonds pour toi puis j'ai
l'impression qu'il y ait beaucoup de
monde que c'est le contraire qui était
si moi j'étais j'ai fait des alignera
une couple de fois mais ces mouches
quelqu'un ggc gbot grande blessure j'ai
bâti puis à chaque fois une expérience
positive téléphone c'était comme juste
du bonheur c'était avec du monde que
j'aime c'était juste une grande et belle
expérience mais c'est tout le temps
c'était tout à récréatif le cette petite
île tada dans un contexte hautement de
nouveaux polos pour trouver ni les
réponses à des questions existentielles
ni pour comprendre l'univers pis ni pour
régler des problèmes qu'elle peut citer
j'ai l'impression que en fait le
problème c'est qu'ils ont voilà pour sûr
mais je pense pas que c'est la bonne la
bonne voie maintenant je pense que
justement ça peut faire ressurgir faire
des batteries enfin pu déjà qu arrive là
bas avec différents objectifs qui
effectivement moi quand j'ai parlé avec
landry elle c'était comme si je me
souviens bien le je veux pas parler à sa
place le mais si je me souviens bien
elle et elle dans un voyage ou en
amérique du sud pour le fun qui avait un
petit ami qui était sur place puis qui
lieu dit hey moi je te tenterait
jugement va faire un trip d'ailleurs
aussi sa tentative est avec moi la
curiosité là dedans qui s'est
probablement guérir des traumas profond
l'inquiète y avait pas de besoin en tant
que tel sans tabou que c'était religieux
non plus on vend tout non non pas entre
eux sont gelés pas sentir du tout comme
somme gelée senti comme la curiosité
puis c'est justement de six mois
essentiellement de la curiosité qui mais
il ya des gens qui arrivent là bas puis
même les études qui ont été faites la
tunisie les gens arrivent là bas pour la
plupart avec des blessures profondes qui
traversent des deuils
ddt des traumas des abus sexuels et
révoque des dépendances beaucoup de gens
qui ont des dépendances à des substances
arrive la bonne passe il pense que les
wascat volet guérir de leur dépendance
enfin que ces tarifs vraiment amochée et
le tu t'en vas dans un contexte
aucunement encadré avec des chamans qui
ont une vision vraiment quand même très
différente du monde qu'on peut avoir
aussi fait qu'effectivement si il y en a
que ça va les a aidés pitt en mieux mais
je pense que tu peux pas faire une
expérience comme celle là certainement
des oies mais qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est toute l'histoire qu'on entend ça
s'est bien passé mais quand ça se passe
mal qu'est ce qui arrive c'est quand on
creuse à ce niveau là tu es comme
huawei qui peut-être que finalement
peut-être que c'est possible
mais moi j'ai fait du lsd une fois la
ville ouais
c'était justement en voyage métissé ça a
donné demain parce que c'est avec des
amis piste et pau encore une fois ce
dépôt une quête spirituelle c'est
vraiment juste comme pour le triple pour
l'expérience maintenant c'est pitié dans
le podcast ou si tu parles beaucoup de
monde qui ceux qui disent que les
expériences qui ont vécu
sur les synergies ce sont les concerts
vrai mettons aussi vrai que la réalité
serait impliqué
puis pour l'avoir fait
quand et dale
moss est convaincu d'avoir
toutes les réponses de lingway était
convaincu d'avoir compris des affaires
je me suis même que je disais ah oui je
sais que tu as perche aux jo
sur teddy office non en tout cas il ya
un personnage est ce que de robert
california qui comme un gars qui parle
encore des paraboles parce que qui amani
je me souviens dans ma soirée lsd
qu'acheter dehors c'est une balle
contrée plus regarder les étoiles il y
avait du monde autour que je leur parle
et puis
la soirée se déroule à la règle est la
même en étant deux fois plus regarder
les étoiles tutelle de stoos
l'avez compris c'est que ça n'a pas de
sens
mais sur le coup puis je me souviens que
je me disais genre je sais que demain je
vais me dire c un boss j'étais
complètement partie ouais puis je me
suis vraiment dit mais je sais que c'est
ça la vérité je sais que là j'ai raison
puis demain je peine à trouver car mais
c'est si le dom 2 en ce moment que la
vérité que la détient médecin pigeard
fait c'est facile d'imaginer
plus être en tête ainsi qu'un autre tu
nous écoutes qui disent ça ils savent
pas de quoi ils parlent mais c'est
facile d'imaginer que le lendemain quand
tu te réveilles tu te rappelles tu as
dit jamais la vérité mais là je me
trouve qu'elles font genre prime
pourrait retourner le web mais je
retourne en vérité ouais mais tu vois ça
coûtera s'imaginer quelqu'un qui reste
seulement à leur métier j'ai dit et je
me souviens aussi quand on écoute et de
pink floyd a
[Musique]
tempêté
mettant le genre de truc qui bouge avec
la musique
c'est vraiment tout laisser tomber tel
était la muse et qu'il est black light
sellette tout les stimuli possible pour
même et on avait une application sera et
palm pixi comme des lumières puis des
formes qui bouge plus comme si ces on
peut passer 1h30 ce l'ipad afin
de présenter les formes
c'est quelque chose là oui dans les
festivals même psychédélique le dans vos
rêves tu te des fois elle est comme
juste des objets qui sont placés là le
pit à quelqu'un qui va passer une heure
de temps juste manipuler l'objet parce
que y vit quelque chose de super intense
au niveau sensoriel visuel auditif que
toi petit come what the fuck mais pour
lui c'est super puissance qui vit
peut-être que lucie trouve là de qbe
melingui
m'étais pris
il ya des réflexions qui était fait
aucun sens que je me souviens qu'ils
émettront les formes qui bougeait ça
avait l'air un peu d'une explosion déjà
des planètes prenait de l'expansion
publié j'imaginais que c'était c'est le
big bang mais tentez n'éclate pink floyd
c'est comme si pink floyd créé le big
bang
est-ce que les briques bang a engendré
pink floyd ou pink floyd entendre ils
big bang j'étais comme ça c'est la
question du
mercy lecoustey comme une vraie question
que je me bats avec
sur
piste et qui sont intéressants dans le
podcast
team et on a cloud security souvent mes
tongs la figure de serpent qui
titre d'amy tu te dis qu'il comprenait
ce que tu vois que la fatwa autorise
enfin témoin de monter des listes d
c'est un moment je tripais d'un gros
philosophie puis trompait d'un gros sur
cette affaire c'était ce qui revenait ce
qu'ils haïssent et istres ces
questionnements la stèle est il des
stores amie line est un peu dans le fond
à ce que je voulais dire c'est que en
réalité les choses sont ces lits les
étoiles lyon pau ils y ont pas une
beauté intrinsèque lyon pau et son fond
juste exister pis le fait qu'on les
trouve belles ou concret d'un sens juste
parce qu'on y 10 - pic on y regarde à
travers nos sens pineau du pin up quand
les décode à travers notre prisme la
réalité mais j'en mettais la banque
le
temps presse aussi c'est sûr que ce
qu'est ce qui est un cumul publication
quitté
qui quittera qu'à ceux qui te suivent ou
les lectures que tu as fait apprécier
dans un moment même toutes sortes tout
se mélange pitt se fait que c'est sûr
que si tu as entendu 14 mille fois
qu'ils 80 yahoo a accueilli un serpent
ça se peut que tu voyais un certain
médecin homme est totalement puisque la
recherche démontre que les expériences
hallucinogènes sont hautement influencé
par l'univers de croyance ou toutes les
préoccupations que toi tu déjeunes en
tapas et seydou diouf ex était obsédé
par un parent un pan de
et pas des hallucinogènes son premier
voire des parlottes c'est aussi simple
que sur le fameux serpent de l'iowa sky
il vient de tout les documentaires qu'on
entend sur l'alcool mais qu'est ce qui a
du sens si j'osais c'est quand on dit je
retrouver du sens à la vie le disque et
que tu il me décrit par mois aux étoiles
quelques pourrait dire moi c'est ça le
sens de ce que j'ai trouvé à la vie puis
c'est correct s'est pas évadé pas de
bonne ou de mauvaise réponse à ce que
c'est je trouve que ce n'est pas un
problème nécessairement ça devient un
problème quand un moment donné tu
commences à penser que la lui si nos
jeunes le psychédélisme ça devient là la
seule façon ou même la façon principale
de trouver des réponses c'est qui ce
genre en parle un peu dans le bal à dos
mais si cette idée là que les drogues de
permettre d'aller chercher rapidement
des réponses à des questions
existentielles que normalement c'est
aurait pris toute une vie à les chercher
je sors c'est pas nouveau le thibault de
l'air d'un âne et 18 ans ils pendent il
critiquait déjà cette idée là que quand
tu prends la drogue tu as l'impression
que tu viens de trouver toutes les
réponses à toutes ces questions et que
c'est une illusion c'est un pic en
réalité les vraies réponses importantes
dans la vie c'est un long cheminement
qui paraît que tu vas y obtenir entre la
cas des doigts ou en prenant une soirée
puisque et des lectures je pense qu'en
notant que la personne est consciente de
ce que ça deviens pas que toutes les
réponses ne viennent pas des psychedelic
ce correctif dans des démarches comme
senna comme celle de nelson avec ses
terrasses et qu'à un moment donné la
personne devient juste c'est comme si
lips collègues deviennent la réponse ce
com mais à partir de maintenant les
réponses je vais les obtenir des
psychedelic puis loeb est là c'est là
qu'un moment donné tu peux t'en peux te
retrouver dans des cheminements qui sont
plus dangereux etc
des fois est-ce que puis peut-être que
peut-être que c'était un petit pont avec
la saison 1 dérive
ce sujet le mais est-ce que des fois
l'idée parce que nelson non tu le dis
dans le podcast que rapidement y avait
pas de fans s'étaient c'était la pire
expérience de sa vie c'est la première
fois je pense une lui qui dit ce qui est
totalement tic appel je pense sa femme
yeux qui piquent ci-dessus la paire
expérience de toute ma vie que je vive
le s qui est un peu l'idée de haut puis
c'est vrai ce jour faire se parler de la
place
je me rappelle plus à qui tu parles mais
qui fait le parallèle avec avec crazy
puis le film film de jean marc vallée
les rituels reste passage les
expériences hors d'alic les expériences
hors d'aller qu est-ce que s'infligent
et la douleur où se mettre à risque
comme moteur pour nous aider à passer à
travers une douleur ou ou s'accepter
nous mîmes qui est ce que est ce que tu
peux trace un parallèle entre rhône et
saône puis histoire que tu suis dans la
saison des reer ou et ça les cdd
s'infliger une douleur tel de vouloir
mourir pour mieux renaître le dans le
fond c'est peut-être le le le parallèle
plus évident à mon avis le haut est
totalement totalement parce que dans la
saison un bon c'est sûr fait que j'ai
exploré
l'histoire de cette fille qui s'est
faite comme met dans une situation
extrême le que c'est pas imaginable pour
le commun des mortels de se retrouver
dans un an tous du plastique pendant
cinq puis et 5 6 7 8 heures 9 heures
d'attenté
dit comment est ce qu'une personne
pourrait penser qu'une expérience de
même vos les aider parce que si c'est de
te mettre dans les pires moments de ta
vie mais après ça va t'aider quinet
nelson c'est la même chose il y en a
parlé beaucoup autour de lui dit à
chaque fois qu avait la pire expérience
de tout ils disaient 'oh mon dieu que ça
et et curatifs puis ça m'a fait du bien
il ya un expert est que je parle le
moment donné non en fait il ya deux
experts que d'autres n'hésitent plus à
faire quasiment similaire l'appui qu'ils
me disent comme c'est souvent justement
des espèces qu'on appelle des
expériences organique c'est justement
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
spontanément si d expansion se met en
danger pour se prouver quelque chose
huit ont l'impression que si tu traverse
cette épreuve le bain après tu vas être
plus fort si ce qui te pottu et au rang
du plus fort reste avant tout un site
idée le maître lui donnait dans crazy
par exemple il ya une scène où le seul
le personnage un moment donné il est pas
bien à l'intérieur qui décident de comme
passer ce une lumière rouge en disant je
parle je parle pas ce phénomène bon il y
avait l'impression que ça allait prouver
quelque chose je pense qu'il veut guérir
vraiment même deux fois dents creuses il
est vrai mais il fait ça avec le scooter
pu ramener sous les pas de ce fait aussi
il ya une grosse tempête de neige puis
les comme dans un magasin de disques
puis 10 capable de me rendre jusqu'à
chez nous pourquoi pas de revenir
jusqu'à pied jusqu'à chez nous je vois
guéri pour lui c'est de l'asthme hélas
mais comme le symbole de son
homosexualité puis il traverse la
tempête plus tu le voyais arriver chez
eux et congelés complètement puisque je
danse dont libya réussi à se rendre m
bah oui pis si ça c'est pas normal d'en
sortir vous vous êtes deux deux athlètes
le jeu aux chaussures que vous avez déjà
vécu des affaires comme
cela les restos jallet pourrait
absolument si j'avais pris qu'il
songeait l'opposé s'était
suicidé fait différente de courir un
marathon et je pense pas marathon c'est
extrêmement douloureux puis pendant
d'emprunter de danse autant de fun que
ce mois là je me souviens que j'étais
allé faire un truc j'ai une fois lille
se fait longtemps notre sueur mais
j'étais allé monter le mont algonquin
dans les adirondacks
pendant la pire tempête de neige de
l'année la pire tempête de neige je sais
pas qu'est-ce qui me prendre mais j'ai
embarqué dans mon char le matin je ris
quand même pas d'un plan non je me lève
je me lève le matin c'est la tempête de
l'année puis je sais pas qu'est ce qui
me prend je ressens le besoin d'aller
monter une des plus hautes montagnes
nature honda cloqué puis j'en faisais
souvent le mais je prends mon change
risque ma vie pendant 2h30 3h de temps
pour me rendre leur des adirondack en
pleine balle de match j'arrive là je
montre la montagne je suis le seul sa
montagne sexy si je meurs là aussi je
t'en veux blesser la personne qui va
m'aider en plus j po et qui peut
échanger des crampons alors que ça me
prendrait des raquettes je monte en haut
puis quand j'arrive en eau le feeling
que j'ai vécu la gelée encore dans mon
coeur je me souviens le quai c'est un
white out je voyais rien tout était de
la cgb l'impression d'être dans un autre
monde mais pour moi le mon expérience
psychédélique de ma vie pour moi c'est
ce qui fait que je pense qu'on en fait
tout des épreuves heures d'aller que man
on a l'impression qu'il faut que tu
prouves de quoi tu te mets en danger
d'après tu fais modique sa cave c'est un
fait ça c'est pas un problème en soi
mais l'eau les deux experts dans mon
balade wamena bémol ce qui dit à un
moment donné ce correct de vivre des
expériences difficiles pour en tirer des
leçons ça c'est même honnêtement c'est
même quelque chose qui manque
présentement ya beaucoup de qui n'ont
pas la chance de vivre ça c'est les
jeunes ont une culture à ce moment vous
sont en plus sûr protégé puis on veut
plus qu'ils aillent se mettre en danger
des choses comme ça ça c'est dommage
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils sont
fondatrices plus formatrices c'est ce
qu'ils ont des expériences m'expliquer
sauf que les faux-pas faut pas commencer
à infiniti chizé ce samedi commence à
fétichisé la souffrance
puis tu développes un certain masochisme
c'est là qu'est le problème je ce
rapidement à ce jeu les pommiers dans le
dal hadopi ça c'est plein deuil que les
savants permettre
le chercheur de meguellati cheval qui
est étudiant en sciences cognitives il
me donne l'exemple des alpinistes ok moi
je trippe sur l'alpinisme les jo j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour les
alpinistes dit à des alpinistes mon père
d'un doigt en monte à l'everest et c'est
un jeu c'est quelque chose le qui aura
énormément de sens pour eux perdre un
doigt c'est pas si grave comparativement
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour eux c'est
quelque chose que ça va être un symbole
à vis de hey ce que j'ai fait le site
important pille on s'en fout du doigt
limites et ça c'est cool l'osce à vienne
ainsi qu une autre cause c'est correct
c'est sa défense lors cette poule c où
la personne n'arrive à se mettre
intentionnellement toujours en danger
qui va tout en se mettant en danger pour
essayer de repousser tout le temps la
limite dans le mayo a accueilli cette
culture le pire on ne peut pas se le
cacher là il ya la culture que plus et
souffrent plus c'est difficile mais plus
tu vas retirer des bienfaits et ce n'est
pas vrai dispo vrai parce que dans le
colonel sommes là il ya eu des
expériences qui aurait dû clairement il
ya des gens qui ont enlevé des flag qui
ont dit ce qu'aulas ne devrait plus
faire de psychédélique à partir de
maintenant c'est l'heure mais à un
moment donné tout un univers qui
n'écoutent pas là dedans puis il
continua l'enfer puis éventuellement
baisse a possiblement été la cause de sa
perte malheureusement
[Musique]
ptc dalphond que je sais pas j'espère
que tu avais pas pensé à se retrouvant
longtemps balade au final font aussi la
dérive la dérive c'est sûr c'est qu'un
petit ont menacé dans ce chemin elop que
le danger parce que tu es d'enchères
datable dans la première saison ses
sauces il sur le temps d'aller plus loin
que c'est une étude document l'ascension
dans les étapes de repousser tout le
temps en plus pour aller chercher tout
le talent les skill plus difficiles les
plus douloureux le plus ouais c'est
drôle parce que en fait c'est vraiment
bizarre parce que des fois les gens me
disent seuil des tailleurs pas beaucoup
le vin de temps en temps j'ai presque
juste des bons commentaires sur des
rythmes et de temps en temps quelques
faits comme son pote dérive est un peu
une connotation négative de dire que
c'est une dérive qui m'ont la raison que
j'ai appelé ces dérives c'est que quand
libre quand j'ai parlé aux proches de
chantal lavigne pour la saison 1 qui ont
dit on a l'impression qu'à dérivés loin
de nous pour rester ça c'était un proche
qui est dans une dérive glee s'éloigne
de ses amis et sa famille moi c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi le dit dérivés non
pas parce que ceux des telles que la
sudation ou que l'aéro à ce que sa
dérive mais en même temps ça peut en
devenir une au site petit chantal dans
la première saison à la vie elle l'avait
dit est déjà proche d'elle elle avait
dit l'heure on a fait beaucoup de rituel
on a fait des tente de sudation qui
était déjà vraiment intense mais c'est
pas assez genre j'attends l'expérience
ultime un manteau neigeux va entendre
une expérience qui avait tellement
intense le petit celle là je vois la
mener jusqu'au bout puis quand je la
vends mener jusqu'au bout je vais avoir
des réponses c'est l'expérience qui a
été fatal c'est comme si comme nelson
pileux on apprend au fur et à mesure du
podcast qu'il ne fait plus de fois qu'on
pense et maintenant vraiment plus loin
mais c'est ce site fait toujours
repousser la limite toujours plus loin
puis tu continues sont soutenus
inévitablement à m'amener il varie de
couette dramatique l'intelligent tôt ou
tard statistiquement il va avoir quelque
chose qui arrive rien c'est comme
séparé d'alpinisme petit je peux te
faire de commentaire fruits sol
c'est incroyable c'est super
impressionnant mais ce goal ou
possiblement trotteurs vont mourir tout
aux statistiquement il va arriver
quelque chose si vous toujours repoussé
les limites qui monte dans le fond c'est
un gars qui gravit des murs naturel pas
attaché puisse la chose la plus
impressionnante au monde mais la plus
épeurante aussi puis le goût est une
forme de radicalisation aussi sont en
forme complètement toute sa vie il faut
que c'est autour de tout ça qui
fonctionne autour de celui-ci comme les
autres peuvent pas comprendre ces cas
qu'on embarque là dedans aussi tu
parlais de chantal nelson ses tuteurs
les autres peuvent pas comprendre c'est
comme une quête spirituelle chantilly
dans quelque chose puis juste moi qui
peux comprendre que dans la nasse et
quand on a dérivé
et
c'est facile
mais dont moi avec la course à pied
c'est le même principe le fond mais
uniquement en anglais au marathon oui
sauf en résultera c'est fait c'est parce
que laisse moi moi c'est plus marathon
marathon et je m'en fous le lendemain
matin et facilement mais je la refais un
demain matin facilement je pense même
plus là c'est le 81 kg près c'est 260 il
ya des courses de 200 miles fait que
c'est des courses de 2 320 kg le ya du
monde qui font ça en ce moment les yeux
du monde sont en train de faire des
plans pour des courses de 500 kg des
courses en montagne pitié aux eaux à
l'ultra trail du mont blanc de cette
année dans le fond c'est la plus grande
compétition de course à pied ouais au
monde en montagne ouais il ya une sous
compétition qui est 80 kilomètres et au
km 11 années ils m'ont fait tomber
dimanche puis le monde il sera content
ça reste encore le saint graal d'ultra
trail c'est sûr mais la différence entre
ce qu'il ya où est ce que je
la plains une différence est que ces
pauvres enfants d'une jungle l'exercice
vise à encadrer ce illégal
de sécurité
où il ya un risque mais vu que c'est
encadré les risques est vraiment très
mal dormi à l'encadrement qu'on parlait
anglais oui on pourrait aussi moi j'ai
pas de chiffre là-dessus mon prix
relativisant design combien de gens qui
sont morts en faisant des ultramarathons
mathon je suis sûr que je faisais les
avantages de se ressembler sérieuse doit
être 0 point 0 1% au même bonne santé
doit ressembler au monde qui ont eu des
problèmes avec la sq avait probablement
parce que tu mets ton je le dis emmené
dans l'est dans le bal à dos le que on
présente au talent est aussi quelque
chose de hautement dangereux dans les
faits il ya pas de tant de gens qui sont
morts que ça se compare à quand une
personne ne voulait y avait des milliers
ou des dizaines de milliers qui en font
chaque année puis dans les dix dernières
années des décès à proprement parler qui
était vraiment dû à la yamaska est en
tête en disait il y en a peut-être plus
que ceci étant dit mais on sentait un
long effort est dans quelque chose
d'autre mais mortel soi même et on a
même échelle mois avec l'alcool c'est le
taux de décès
oui exact facture je pense que c'est
pareil comme je devrais ce qu'est ce
qu'il faut s'empêcher de faire des
ultramarathons parce que il ya des gens
qui meurent de tout ça non mais à un
moment donné c'est sûr que tu peux te
retrouver dans une situation à mener ou
serre c'est comme toi exemple j'ai fait
une couple de fois qu'on se voit le web
un petit trip sur le marathon mais en
même temps tu es une personne épanouie
taux plein de passion dans vite appeler
un intérêt et une vie qui est riche
c'est ta vie aux pauvres c'est je suis
sûr que le sens à ta vie vient pas juste
du fait que tu cours des marathons non
c'est sûr tandis que quand le sens à ta
vie devient juste pour justement si moi
je pense constamment sur une paroi
rocheuse où je suis à deux doigts de la
mort ma vie au pas de sens ici si je
peux en train de faire de l'iowa score
en train de vomir mes tripes qui de deux
passés à deux doigts de la mort ou de ma
vie n'a pas de sens c'est essayer le
problème tant il ya des gens qui vont se
retrouver le
le
dain dans dans ta première saison
kaka on apprend que injuste rester sous
les couvertures alors qu'il est
techniquement être pouvait s'en aller si
vous voulez le sauvetage avait
l'impression que c'est comme si
quelqu'un te disais
reste sous l'eau puis si tu t'en sors la
tête de l'eau le bas était faible là
c'est que tu réussis à truquer ton
esprit a juste passé au dessus de tes
instincts primaires de survie ouais ce
jeu si tu étais un stand survivre sur ce
lot c'est terrible c'est dans le cas de
chantal l'oncle et le cas de la saison 1
en dessus découverte ils faisaient au
dessus de 42 cas ce qui le fait le total
est autant essayer tu t'es tu t'es prête
un peu au jeu j'ai fait une version
mollo de ce pape qui apprennent devenir
le sport où je le faisais mon idole
c'est ça a été sorti j'étais rendu à 39
ans tu découverte on s'entasse à aller
juste monté plus que sur le fait qu elle
en dessous de tout ces bâches de
plastique faisant faire il faisait une
quarantaine de degrés avaient la tête
dans une boîte avec leur pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils allaient continuer c'est la
grande question puis en cours quand il
ya eu le procès pour les personnes qui
dirigent et ça les avocats de la défense
ont dix heures ça a été les avocats de
la défense les avocats de la défense ce
qui représentait les personnes à la
taille de la du rituel de sudation dit
le les gens étaient pas obligés de
rester mais pouvait se lever qui
partirait au fait pourquoi est-ce que
vous accusez ma cliente qui est celle
qui dirigeait le séminaire c'est pas de
sa faute elle les germes un cas s'élever
s'il était plus capé bien que celui pas
repartir mais c'est de minimiser un
paquet d'affaires bon un
l'influencent d'avoir une personne en
position d'autorité au dessus toi qui
est à l'avant de la salle c'est comme tu
dis là quelqu'un dit je reste en dessous
de lola mais tu veux rester en tout au
plus longtemps si cette personne là pour
toi est une autorité unique un e-reçu
deuxièmement il ya tout l'endoctrinement
dans son cas elle c'était des mois et
des mois et des mois de ce fait rentrer
dans tête un paquet de concepts que à
l'audit roma encore le des thèmes
récurrents mais j'entendais c'est peu
dire qu'elle avait d'être homo issus de
vie antérieure priant dans d'elle
puisqu'elle avait besoin de se purifier
par des choses comme ça fait beaucoup de
parallèles à fort ya tellement de la
rall elle est pas pour rien que la mère
de nelson quant à l'écouté il dérive
saison c'est là qu'elle a accepté de
parler parce que le fait même j'ai
l'impression d'écouter l'histoire de
nelson mais la sudation cela est-ce que
ça qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya l'autorité
l'endoctrinement il ya le fait que toi
même des rangers je veux te mettre en en
or des lignes tout bête mais tu en as tu
vas aller au bout de soi-même pour te
prouver quelque chose qui avons
l'impression de se retrouver un sens
puis dans le cas de chantal yeux ou si
un autre phénomène qui était qu'elle
avait la tête dans une boîte de carton
puis probablement qu'elle avait une
intoxication ou au dioxyde de carbone
donc quand on expire on les inspire du
co2 qui est probable qu'ils le co2
c'était problème est accumulée depuis
que magna était un peu plus conscients
d'après m pour lemaitre les quatre
premières heures ou peut-être les trois
premières
étapes est consciente qu'ils étaient
capables mais peut-être que la
dernière-heure honnêtement elle a été
tout le long jamais qui avait manqué les
dix jeunes dont six dans sa boîte de
carton alors midi une boîte de carton
pas de carton pour que tu manqueras
d'oxygène mais fait 40 en place là
je l'essayé le puits après une demi
heure je le sentais les finances 2010 un
montant
non le g - une fois c'est pas là que
j'ai enlevé toutes les sacres l'est
aussi quand j'ai fait le montant mais ce
que tu lis ça m'ennuie quand une
pression qui s'installe t comme je vais
pas bien en ce moment être qui se passe
je respire pas normalement ta
respiration et le match commence à
entrer en hyperventilation passé encore
récent d'aller chercher plus d'oxygène
n'est pas capable moi c'est une demi
heure elle à le rester selon les estimés
au moins cinq heures et demie minimum
c'est le cas partir de quel moment n'est
à leur juste perdu à carte puis
extrait mélange de tout ces facteurs là
c'est terrible les les
enregistrements que tu veux jouer dans
la saison 10 à ne pas vraiment un
enregistrement de ses décisions seul
homme est dans la saison il y en a je le
manque en effet c'est à gabriel
fréchette se sont associés tels elle a
lâché qu'un café possédé par une entité
que ça vous a changé depuis que les
cracks et puis les enregistrements de ce
super cutter même si ça me donne la
chair
écoute moi aussi pour mettre un peu de
contexte pour ceux qui l'ont pas écoutée
dans le fond c'est que celle qui
dirigeait le séminaire de sudation
l'ajustement en question elle a 10 x
dépôt elle qui décide de faire ces
activités leur a dit qu'ils avaient une
entité une entité surnaturelle qui
s'appelle melchisédech
qui est une incarnation de jésus le met
en tout cas dans le monde new age qui
rentrait dans réel si cette entité là
qui parlait à sa place mais que ça va
changer son vocabulaire change et c'est
l entité qui décidez combien de temps va
durer la sudation paix que ces thérapies
moi j'ai écouté le tir quelqu'un qui
m'avait donné à l'époque une boîte le
immense avec des tables fait dévier
cassin j'ai écouté quand j'écoute et 25
cas cette loge écouter chez plus combien
d'heures de stock ni amende ni le banni
tu viens de sensibiliser mais sa voix
change lemonnier si gabriel qui parle
tout seul puis à un moment donné après
c'est une autre voie puis le sait comme
assise fauqué en tabarnouche là c'est
vraiment vraiment fauqué puis c'est moi
j'ai encore le 1-1 des préjugés que
j'avais par rapport à ça dans la saison
ainsi que moi je me disais être
clairement ça c'est quelqu'un qui
quelqu'un qui pense que des entités
vient en aide efficacement à parler
qu'une autre voix c'est clairement
témoin cette personne-là est
schizophrène bolt j'ai parlé un
psychiatre spécialisé la dai et comme
papa te papa en turquie comme non il ya
des gens qui croient qu'ils croisent ils
pensent que l'identité qui rentrent en
un pic qui vient parle à leur place ce
nom pas de troubles de santé mentale
pantois de son jeu 100% convaincu que
c'est en train de se produire mais si
que c'est pas un rôle de santé mentale
c'est quoi mais savez vous pourquoi
est ce à dire est ce que tu entends par
un trouble de santé mentale c'est si tu
parles d'une maladie mentale d'une
pathologie c'est quoi des pathologies
tirait pas en dépression et pas en
entier t es pas schizophrène et pas
bipolaire pas psychose après c'est quoi
elle est peut-être un trouble de
personnalité quelqu'un quelconque sas
promis une
pathologie de santé mentale qui fait que
les gens sont soignés des médicaments et
hospitalisés n'ont
fait que l'un des méchants
questionnements ou une maison c'est
aussi ça me ramène dans la saison 2 dans
le sens où ça montre à quel point on
peut se convaincre quelque chose puis
avoir l'impression garde juste faire un
parallèle rapide j'en parle rapidement
dans le dal balado d'ailleurs à ce qu'à
mais il ya une étude qui a été faite
amegee louions rarement c'est plein
d'étudiants dans un sous-sol une pièce
super psychédélique tirs avec des murs
il y avait mis toutes les rues colorées
l'immeuble il leur en donner une
substance en dix ans ne risquez d qui
sont tout le monde s'est mis à
halluciner 61% déjà soumis à halluciner
c'était une pilule de suc
incroyable 60% est ce qu'il ya un
trouble de santé mentale non ça montre
juste à quel point est ce que
la puissance de notre imaginaire tournée
qui a pas de ce conte - le je suis
capable de me convaincre que les
peintures bouge il ya même des gens dans
l'étude en question les qui disaient
qu'ils avaient vécu une expérience
spirituelle profonde il y avait rien
pris il y avait pris une pilule de sucre
vivre une expérience spirituelle
profonde est accessible en théorie à
n'importe qui n'ont pas besoin d'un
gyroscope ça cool taxi
s'est jamais été convaincu sa main qui
prenait quelque chose de psychédélique
donc convaincu les faits mais
imaginez les gens déjà convaincu qu' en
plus plein c'est quelque chose qui est
réellement ce qui est délicat et
décupler mon wifi dans le cas de
l'ayahuasca moi c'est un des aspects qui
m'a le plus troublé là c'est qu'il ya
des études qui démontre que les gens
développent en fait même des croyances
purement développe des croyances
religieuses après avoir fait des
expériences comme ça j'ai des gens qui
font comme en ont moins la religion joue
un soir de cap après ce jeu comme moi
maintenant je crois
je sais pas quoi là
peu importe la patente que j'ai vu c'est
comme toi te quant au fait exprès de
laisser des tuteurs penser à des étoiles
pink floyd il y en a qui voient une
personne qui leur parle il ya une fille
à qui j'ai parlé qui a pas voulu être
enregistré comme indiqué à le prix de
l'ayahuasca puis là il ya une femme qui
est venue la voir une femme qui venait
la voir puis qui le dit qui parle en
anglais lui qui parle en anglais en plus
comme comme le rappelle un peu le genre
sur les criminels qui venait
il ya une entité qui s'appelle
en fait si j'essaie de me souvenir
exactement dit ce qu'elle a dit le maire
de couilles à une femme qui arrive c'est
une femme qui est un mail à une femme
avec comme dit un peu un mélange de
femmes plantes à la part elle arrive du
ciel paye parle pas ici
du you want to die
for
le la personne répond à moins de te dire
whitmarsh it feel olalalala l'entité
fait comme ok il donne comme 8 me pis là
à ce moment là elle dit cassé senti
propulsé dans les airs jusqu'à se
retrouver dans l'espace et le vus comme
assez vu quitter la ville où étaient
pialet vu la terre puis comme dans
google earth le camp des battus des
hommes la terre il était dans l'espace
qu'il a vu la terre puis l'univers tout
ça puis l'après seule entité il l'a fait
atterrir à des places gens chez eux chez
ses parents d affaires de cette ville
qui comme tabarnouche choisir
quelqu'un casseurs de c'est sûr que
cette file une
divinité lui mais comme tu dit elle
quand est arrivée la halle avait déjà lu
des tonnes de fer là dessus à laver lui
que quand tu fais de l'ayahuasca se rend
compte une divinité qui s'appelle mamaya
wascat qui ressemble à une femme qui est
une plante à votre te promener à travers
le monde pas souvent c'est ce que les
gens disent avoir promené à votre fard
voir différents tableaux avant de faire
des révélations sur ta vie à votre poser
des questions donc en réalité ça alors
fauqué mai en réalité ce qu'elle a vu
c'est ce qu'elle s'attendait à avoir à
le manifester totalement
c'est fou mais tes excuses mais c'est
juste moi mettons dans l'expérience
qu'ils étaient cent fois moins intenses
que ceux qui étaient quand même vraiment
intense avec le type parfait tu mets ton
du match après dix mois je sais rien
mais ton gabarits du lsd moi c'est loin
c'est
mérité d'être convaincus que les
réflexions piketty quelle espèce de
vérité que j'avais trouvé le étaient des
réelles vraiment de vivre une expérience
comme ceux comme s'ils y étaient puis en
étant convaincus c'est vrai pendant que
ça arrive je peux comprendre qu'après
s'être échangé lundi noir pour tous pour
toujours nous tiens
il ya un terme qui a été qu'ils existent
pour ça ça s'appelle on dit que les
visions associés ou psychédéliques et
une qualité noétique la sauce et là
c'est la conviction que ce que tu vis
est réel un fait que c'est pas juste de
dire le si c'est pas une question d'être
quelqu'un d'intelligent ou d'avoir de
l'esprit critique les stérols quand tu
vis les hallucinations ce qui se passe
en syrie est ton cerveau il est
convaincu d'être toutes les mécaniques
sont en place pour que tu dis ça c'est
vrai c'est en train de se produire en ce
moment qu'est après ben c'est sûr que
moi ce que j'aurais envie parce que je
voudrais pas qu'on ait l'air de juger
les gens qui font ces expériences web et
wap dans l'effectif des belles robes de
bal du projet certains puis surtout mon
amour et mon expérience étaient
positives égalisait puis georges ans
j'en parle avec les plus grands des
tudors je vois pas à faire la promotion
métier - est positif pis si je dis pas
que j'ai eu avec une expérience
spirituelle l'incroyable qui est mais
si comme n'importe quelle expérience de
vie mark kent le temps de vie marquant
de ce que ça va changer un petit peu
peut-être le ti et peut-être pour le
meutre est possible si je pense que
l'important c'est d'abord en fait il ya
une personne qui me disent on un moment
donné vers la fin du bal adopte une
personne qui a fait beaucoup d'ailleurs
au scope ghamdi un moment donné elle
même a lieu à lui un moment donné un
recul assez fait comme eux alors réalisé
que dans ce milieu losc était pas
beaucoup valoriser c'était de prendre un
peu de recul
deux des 40 et l'expérience puis de
prendre le temps nécessaire pour
réfléchir à ce que tu as vécu puis c'est
quoi la suite qui paie elle dans son
cocon est le fait de ceux à nos parfaite
d'éventuellement peut-être pour soi ou
pour d'autres raisons soit ça la regarde
mais mais mais ça s'apprend ça fait que
je pense que je sais je pense que c'est
pas de juger les gens qui ont soit mais
c'est plutôt de dire la distance
critique là puis le temps de réflexion
faut que tu le prennes site enchaîne les
expériences psychédéliques un honneur de
l'autre sans prendre le temps de les des
40 et de questionner tout le temps ou
pourquoi je fais ça est ce que j'en ai
encore besoin d'être qu'est ce que je
vais aller chercher de plus à mon avis
est peut-être là le risque un moment
donné tout à fait seule fois qui a prêté
comme intéressant mais c'est moi j'ai
pas une attirance vers la drogue en
général tu fais midi pour une couple de
fois dans ma vie je vois pas tant
l'alcool c'est peu dans ma nature
puisque comme a été proposée par des
amis dans un contexte vraiment spécial
après sou je ressens pas le besoin de
refaire ce que je leur ferai dans ma vie
peut-être mais déjà métissée mais c'est
ce que c'est si tu vois là pour régler
des problèmes puis là une faute il fait
on dit bien le foot leur phase il faut
faire face et de pointer un jour vivre
juste pour faire de l'ayahuasca
l'utiliser si tu peux pas j'ai toujours
donné chez vous a bien fait je suis
guéri savamment et métis si tout le
temps en renfort offert par les plus
loin le plus loin c'est quand même ça
guérit rien farm ans et enfonce dans
quelque chose ben oui puis aller à
linverse quelqu'un qui rêve qui dirait
j'en ai fait une fois puis ça a été une
expérience super importante pour moi
dans ma vie puis je suis jamais retourné
puis peut-être commander mais on a des
gens que j'ai parlé que c'était ce genre
et ça a été une expérience incroyable
bourse aux jouets retourne toujours
pas de nom c'est clair puis un tir tu
parlais des gens qui sont devenus
croyants après avoir fait après avoir
fait sur mon ami que je parlais tantôt
quand il y en a fait une couple de fois
il dit matile lui n'est pas
nécessairement et croyant en la
réincarnation puis dans le bouddhisme
ces choses là mais il me dit
après avoir vu ce que j'ai vu
j'ai de la misère à penser que ça se
finit dans notre compte - ce que
j'imagine que c'est peut-être quelque
chose qui te bute entendu le parce que
tout le temps qu'il me dise est après
avoir vu seul maintenant vu ou est-ce
que j'étais allé pendant pendant ce
triple après avoir après avoir vu ce que
j'ai vu la misère à penser que ça se
finira juste une
lettre le corps humain et
un parallèle qu'on peut faire c'est les
expériences de mort imminente
oui d'ailleurs dans la communauté it is
qu'on appelle la communauté
psychédélique le sait pas ici de monde
qui tripent sur les drogues
psychédéliques mais aussi sur d'autres
expériences comme beaucoup de gens la da
qui font de la méditation puis qui
disent que ça les amène dans les états
de conscience altéré ou des choses comme
ça
les espaces de mort imminente le tc des
gens qui sont morts qui ont vu des
affaires souvent quand ils reviennent
après et 10 écoute j'ai vu une lumière
j'ai vu c'est judicieux c'est clair pour
moi maintenant que après la mort il ya
qu'il ya de quoi après ben c'est sûr que
je peux être prêté sept différentes
façons par exemple déjà des travaux qui
ont démontré de façon assez convaincante
que la famille le fameux tunnel que tu
vois quand tu meurs il ya une
explication relier je pense aux nerfs ou
nerf optique c'est mon papa
sélectionne le dernier capteur qui
s'amenait dans ton cerveau si le nerf
optique fixe et fait que tu vois de la
lumière a fait quelque chose comme
sortie donc une explication 100%
rationnelle un autre exemple qui me
tombe un des secteurs où notre cerveau
est le plus en hallucinations c'est dans
life dans les rails le toit d'un des
affaires mais quand tu travailles de ton
rêve tu dis pas mike hodges juin
autrement les nuls ce monde-là exister
un donc qu'est ce qui fait qu'un rêve on
les associe pas la réalité mais que
certaines la société certains il voit
c'est vrai des présages là effectivement
pilot c'est là qu'on voit que tout
l'univers de croyances bien jouer là
dedans c'est ça avez vous déjà entendu
parler de la paralysie du soleil c'est
la paralysie du sommet pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ce aussi un instinct une
pathologie de semaine est un trouble du
sommeil lent qui fait que au moment où
tu t'endors ton ton corps t-il le corps
est paralysée concentre donc toutes nos
l'ailé jonction neuromusculaire qu'on
appelle donc toutes les nerfs c'est end
on ne peut plus bouger mais le prendre
c'est que ces gens-là ce qui arrive
c'est que juste après que leurs corps se
soit paralysé il se réveille mais ils
peuvent plus bouger fait qu'ils sont
paralysés pis alors que tu vois des
affaires fauqué leur arrivée du sérieux
comme arrêtée mais pas l'intérieur
c'est décrochement plus je me réveille
en hurlant mes emplois pas bouger puis à
un essai en mode est vrai mais il ne
s'est jamais réveillé mais on n'entend
pas vraiment capable mais
le monde puis petit tout malentendu créé
la nuit en tipi et west ham et hervé
quand même plusieurs fois le de curling
est comme paralysée et puis de serment
par le fond puis ça a l'air vrai ah
ouais avec la paralysie du sommeil puis
plus largement aussi ce qu'on appelle
les hallucinations hypno logique tout ce
qui se passe dans notre cerveau au entre
au moment où tu t'endors c'est georges
tu en prennes m'endormir ton cerveau il
fait voir des enfants tu peux avoir des
hallucinations auditives visuelles
sensorielle pendant que tu t'endors le
fameux avoir l'impression de tomber ou
de voir des formes d'entendre quelqu'un
parler puis la paralysie du soleil c'est
la version extrême de tueur et ses
mécanismes là c'est l'explication
principale
pour que pour tous les phénomènes
paranormaux depuis le début de
l'histoire l'humanité les enlève en fait
les enlèvements par des extraterrestres
la possession des monique la part des
ddd dément
les visites par des fantômes c'est la
principale hypothèse pour expliquer tous
ces phénomènes la paix que ça veut dire
que pendant des milliers d'années les
êtres humains ont vécu ces choses là qui
sont tout à fait normal on pourrait
citer tellement réel que c'est en baisse
et des démons qui me possède c'est des
fantômes c'est des extraterrestres qui
me
[Musique]
viennent de m'enlever alors qu'une
explication tout à fait rationnel après
ben c'est sûr que les gens sont libres
de choisir l'expression de leur vol si
tu fais un trip de l'est depuis que tu
vois un monstre ben tu peux décider que
le monde qui est vrai ou tu peux dire
c'est l'hallucination
c'est sûr que c'est difficile à
contester avec la personne en partage
une fois j'avais fait dans mon livre
qui le je me souviens que j'avais vu
dans ma chambre une femme homme enfant
tons bleus transparents qui fêtait
d'evry dans dans le plafond de la
chambre qui disait c'est ma maison c'est
ma maison comme si on était dans sa
maison
puis j'aurai moi j'étais convaincu que
j'avais vu un fantôme et et puis genre
de la même attention je dormais la même
chose qu'à mon frère médias étaient
agités par anton sommet toute la nuit de
supermarché des cauchemars le député
mais à ce moment là le mot j'avais vu un
fantôme le jeter je raconte et c'est
justement à une amie qui est un gros
astrologie et spiritualité du seul un
tipi le jt avec la ces sources un esprit
fga c'est un cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar un cauchemar où une
hallucination et pédagogique parce que
souvent tu vas dire aux gens c'était
sûrement rail four communal on se
comprend pas le jeter et veiller ce
n'est pas un rêve mais c'est plus parce
que notre cerveau hallucine qui
historiquement presque toutes les
visions d'esprit pitt fantôme audois
devront presque de capture fait de vrais
recension que j'ai eu ça donc j'ai lu un
livre là-dessus ce n'était pas ça me
fascine depuis presque tout dans
l'histoire d'humanité les moments où il
ya eu des vrais fantômes qui ont été vus
ou peu importe d esprit c'était presque
toujours à un moment où la personne est
un moment qui tente les vieilles pies le
soleil ou le soir tard ou tir gardien de
sécurité qui dit je vais je veille au
grain mais en réalité commence à cogner
des clous en titre
sept soldats la trouve vraiment mis ses
mails aux jo ça m'est arrivé comme un
jour de paralysie du sommeil puis jetée
dans une maison avec
une garde d'enfant un band avec ont
enregistré 6 dans mon sommeil
c'est comme voir les yeux plutôt dans la
chambre je te coucher dans mon lit puis
un dégoût du bain qui rendrait au chant
qui m'a quand même fait des
attouchements votre force et paquets
plus me réveiller et j'ai crié pis les y
était pas le
méjean jeter comme ça arriverait pas
arrivés sa femme était évidemment le
gisti je suis combien absolument 100%
convaincu mais genre cjad
d'hallucinations d'expérience c'est
comme si quand est ce qu'un quantifier
joue très bien en irak puis comme 1 200
go n'était pas sûr si c'est vrai ou faux
dreno après si tu reviens d esprit mais
l'estac hommes c'est comme seul mais
échanger les vues petit j'étais dans ma
chambre j'avais ouvert je les ai vus
mais je peux comprendre qu'ils ont
interprétés comme il ya des rêves qui
ont une qualité noétique qui semblent
incroyablement réel ya même des
médicaments qu'on prescrit aux gens des
fois on trouve des médicaments pour la
malaria qui augmente
l'aspect poétique des rêves donc les
gens ils vont vers surplus plus vrai oui
exact examen
médical entre autres condamnés pour la
malaria les gens qui vont en afrique des
choses comme ça que ça donne du rêve
tellement réel que quand les gens font
un cauchemar ils sont ils sont
traumatisés fait qu'à un moment donné
l'armée américaine oba nist médicaments
leur parce que disait c'est un
un escadron un militaire l'afrique qui
prennent des médicaments la malaria et
de couleurs appelé mieux de la nuit il
pense qu'un bombardement puis qui
pensent que c est vrai la qui se lève
puis qui se met à tirer seulement nous
fouillent - l'âge de 100 ans du
dangereux russe à une question de
sécurité et le fait que ça montre qu'un
rêve le sapeur ça ça peut être aussi
réelles qu'une trip psychédélique
comme tu dis apprêtée comme suit
vraiment a revu cette affaire là où
paupières donc à moins de rebonds puis
il ya des fois il ya des fois en plus
même
si folle que ça fait puis c'est là que
tu dis quand tu peux jouer avec la
chimie il peut se passer bien enfants
dans ta tête mais
des fois ça arrive parce que tu te
réveilles puis toute la journée il comme
tu es comme dans un doute de ce qu est
ce que ce que te rêver c'est vrai pis
depuis quelque chose là dedans qui
existent encore en une journée complète
le mois mais ça m'arrive quand même ces
fous pareils de quoi
des fois même ton fils un an voir
quelqu'un est modifiée par le fait que
rêver à cette personne là j'ai invité de
monsieur avec moreno mais genre
mais moi je me souviens quand j'étais
jeune au secondaire le genre mettront
leurs tiges possède déjà arrimée sur
evans fille s'était jamais intéressée
elle particulièrement mais dans ton rêve
tout comme une idylle romantique avec
elle ou de quads et sexuelle ou à river
le pilote de couleurs mais tu es comme
un peu en amour avec la vie
c'était tellement puissant ce que tu as
vécu contexte une connexion que cette
personne-là qu'avant jamais considéré je
me suis que sa mère une couple de fois
dans ma vie ça montre à quel point ce
que ça y est puissante mais bien mais si
on leur suspect cialis ou le sommeil ou
de podcasts puis bref qui s'intéressent
au drive roger roger qui est extrêmement
intuitive dire en sommeil le cerveau
process d affaires qui règlent des
affaires avec des dossiers petif
accueilli quelque chose
qui était sans doute sans signification
mais c'est quand même ton cerveau qui
fait de l'ordre dans tout seul on this
way se situe aussi du processing des
émotions des souvenirs en gros le fait
que pierre même d'autres du potage
possible en oeuvre riche et plus il en a
parlé dans le podcast mais il ya même
des idées chercheurs qui ont émis
l'hypothèse que leur arrive ça pourrait
être
un mécanisme évolutif pour nous préparer
à certaines expériences autrement dit
que si tu rêves à certaines affaires que
top a déjà vécu bien que ça pourrait
représenter un avantage dans l'évolution
parce que tu serai mieux préparé quand
ça se produit pour de vrai ou même
d'autres hypothèses qui disent que ce
serait une façon de généraliser des
expériences très spécifique à d'autres
affaires de la victime plein
d'hypothèses dans ce domaine là
on avait parlé la première chose que
vous motive mais jamais comment met-on
et
vivre un deuil comme des gens un peu
processus
c'est une des hypothèses secondaire du
rêve à ma connaissance
je revenir un peu sur sur des riffs
parce qu'il pleut je veux pas je pose
pas et les parce que s'il ya quand même
une certaine certaines trames narratives
nippone à suivre et qui t'amène à chaque
ya des punchs quand même assez des
affaires que tu veux pas qu'on compte
qu'on
dévoileront les enlèvera scorer mais
chut fait quand même des découvertes par
rapport qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec
nelson des affaires que toi tu met en
lumière que personne d'autre avant ou
dans la version officielle
ont pas été mis en lumière comment tu te
sens quand ça arrive c'est mettons je
pense à un honnête je parle avec une
ancienne
marie fille qui travaillait là puis
c'est une actrice qui fait sa voix le
pied là tu racontes
l'espèce de
cinq six jours avant les ailes à l'issue
des choses que personne savait c'est
savoir que toi tu apprends ce qu'est ce
qui se passe quand tu apprends sur ton
coeur
ben oui c'est sûr c'est sur pied en même
temps je pense que c'est comme si de
côté le temps seul puis le late
apparaître tourne à 100 milles à l'heure
mon coeur moi je me souviens le temps
sermonnant poitrine dont on a fait tout
ce qui était en train d'apprendre à
faire avancer en même temps moins une
personne n'est que je mets
tout le talent est en train de me dire
attends plus le progrès alors que je
comprends barça après pied que ces
thérapies
texte est un mélange d'émotions vraiment
un temps ces entrefaits des choses dans
ce que tu apprends pour pas tomber trop
spécifique il est juste que tu apprends
à ce moment là que tu ignores même sais
de quoi tu parles demandez-le en parle
de
maintenant on parle de quelque chose que
nelson aurait finalement que qui
possiblement ce qui a été la cause de sa
mort finalement battu sur le coup puis
comme j'ai aucune idée de ce que tu me
parles c'est quoi le blé fokam explique
fokam appelle les mots des affaires
étrangères et des frissons quand
je trouvais en plus
mais je suis content que tu me dis ça
parce que moi je voulais que ça soit la
vraie voix de la personne qui est à
parle en anglais la vraie personne qui a
fait ça de celle que j'appelle louisa
puis finalement la dernière minute quand
je lis recontacter indien et tout est
cool a pour le documentaire a fait ce
n'est pas ma voix moment gueule puisque
j'ai fait aux chiffres qui s'était mal
compris si un tel cas le changer d'idée
en cours de route puis tout avec moi
j'avais pas quelque chose qui se perdent
non mais avec la comédienne on ne
travaille un peu pour que ça sort bien
mais
oui tu as l'impression lequel étienne
des grès de quad super groupe qui non
seulement ça ça dépasse aussi aux mines
dans un sens mais après il ya aussi le
sentiment aux warning de comminges
offert pour corroborer soeur aurait ce
puis je me souviens moi je travaille
avec avec des gens à radio canada entre
autres avec avec joignez la rue qui est
la machette de contenus chez radio
canada qui est la personne qui
m'accompagne le plus puis j'ai dit à
locoal écoutant ce moment qui je me
souviens que joannie a m'avait dit
amener quelque chose que c'est une
phrase que momar kâ maudit moi ma plus
grande peur c'est que on sache ce que
c'est pas aussi mais conclure ici j'aime
elle dit
la cause que vous pouvez pas le coloris
exact en mettant le quelqu'un me dit
olivier là moi je le sais ce qui s'est
passé c'est ça et que c'est la seule
personne qui me fait cette version
l'heure mais moi je peux pas le dire
c'est la différence entre ce que dit on
jasait au tout début le débat la dôle et
c'est ce qui fait la différence ensemble
si moi je décide de faire ma propre
enquête puis de faire une vidéo youtube
là dessus c'est fine mais je peux dire
ce que je veux puis après tout exposé à
la peut-être je sais pas des poursuites
et
dans un contexte utre avec d'énormes tu
peux pas faire ce avec moi c'est sûr que
ma petite fille née à cause de ce qui
était envisagé c'est de comprendre
j'essayais de la suivre puis en même
temps j'étais quand même comment est ce
que je vais faire pour valider ce après
tirs comme prendre deux ou trois
personnes qui me confirme cela
idéalement 3 le pilote eut dit elle ça
m'a tout pris cette ville en particulier
à qui je parle moi je trouve que ça
relève du miracle que tu as pu parler
mais totalement parce que la façon je
les trouvais cesson son nom apparaissait
dans des commentaires dans différents
endroits mais son nom il était tout le
temps un bar aurait pu même année j'ai
remarqué que quand les jambes à auray
parce que les gens ont tout le temps
peur au monde ce n'était qu'un partage
des commentaires les premiers
screenshots qui après un reportage de
screenshots mais bon le nom de la
personne pour moi que moi même je fais
sur le camp je partage des commentaires
mais tout le monde parle et non un peu
différemment avec des fois tu vois le
baudet il est des fois tu vois le aux
délais avec moi je mettrais inconstante
ouais moi je m'étais créé comme un
espèce de pain dans ton bureau même du
gain essaie d'expliquer un routeur
rumeurs sur un tableau blanc
j'avais tout coller les trois je pense y
avait trois ou quatre places que j'avais
vu son nom qui est un endroit où on
voyait la presse que la première lettre
au complet ya des moments où on voyait
juste le haut des leurs pieds des monts
et injuste le bas puis remaniée où on
voyait l'interface entre son prénom son
nom de famille j'ai collé comme de façon
super artisanale le gie fait ça à l'air
de soi ça ou de 6,20 les autres à faire
là s'est testé j'étais comme j'ai testé
des combinaisons dans facebook encore
une fois un jusqu'à ta camani et gérer
la photo serait juste précis j'avais la
photo du profil c'est toi comme la photo
est après tout un homme lombard qui fuit
l'homme en est à force d'essayer des
combinaisons d'un coup je vois la photo
de la fille que j'ai fait aux marques de
la brée tu dois me répondra jamais
pierre ammeux réponse et une autre près
de 6 et comment j'ai toujours voulu
comment parler mais j'ai jamais osé
officier
tu te fais qu'apporter os capoté parce
que c'est au final c'est pas mal on le
sait pas mais c'est pas mal seul
le couple le suspect numéro un dans
l'histoire la version qu'elle a maudit
de ski c'est parce qu'elle allait comme
à le travailler là bas plusieurs années
a connu tout le monde là-bas y retourner
même sur place après pour poser des
questions des choses comme ça puis a
maudit car moi mon hypothèse principale
sur ce qui s'est passé c'est telle chose
puis après ça j'ai comme plusieurs
autres personnes qui m'ont dit la même
affaire puis aussi d'autres témoignages
que j'ai eus qui m'ont qui fit est le
coup c'est comme s'il y avait plein de
morceaux de kraft ait profité tout
ensemble mais c'est sûr qu'après malgré
tout sur moi je pourrai jamais dire
c'est sûr que c'est pas aussi fait qu'un
moment donné il ya un travail que
l'auditeur doit faire du douaisis
d'urbain garde on saura jamais mais je
pense qu'en ce moment on peut se faire
une bonne idée et loties comme parce que
la grande question dans le code nelson
c'est ce qui a été rapporté dans
l'immédiat c'est que s'était suicidé en
suicides lost un mot qui est chargé le
c'est un gros mot suicide c'est pour moi
je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas c'est
quoi pour vous un suicide ou pour les
gens mais pour moi un suicide c'est
vraiment s'enlever la vie parce que tu
veux plus vivre de ce traité va
longtemps mais pour moi c'est ceci donc
ans a été rapporté dans les mythiques
c'est un suicide quand le propriétaire
du chanteur dit non non non ici suicider
c'était son choix
moi je comme fait moi la grande question
que je laisse avancer - c'est ça la
vraie question c'est le détail précis de
ce qui s'est passé est moins important
que nous ayons sasp et ux togolais qui
avait une belle vie qui avaient l'air
heureux qu'il y avait des difficultés
quand même on se le cachera pas on
découvre à travers la balado qui
vivaient des choses difficiles comme
tout le monde ils vont faire la loi mais
ça mais aussi comme c'est le dos et
c'est ces difficultés étaient des
difficultés somme toute qui existe dans
ville qui ce courant depuis que des gens
vivent ça au quotidien rien que tu
apprennes que tu fais là oh my god c'est
sur ce lancer tout des artistes comme à
ben oui c'est des choses qu'on peut
vivre avec mon pied puis aussi je sais
que la famille ce qui leur faisait le
plus mal c'est de perdre leur enfant
c'est la pire en fait je peux même pas
imaginer que ce que c'est mais une des
choses qui leur restait c'est l'idée du
suicide c'est comment est-ce que
mongongu mon frère ou peut s'enlever la
vie de ce ça correspondait pas avec
l'image avec moi ce que je voulais c'est
essayer beaucoup de détails et cette
hypothèse le média sas plus que cette
gold ce soit enlevé la vie de
délibérément à la limite pour moi
c'était plus important d'étudier ce que
trouver le détail la sphère précise jane
se rassure je savais que je pourrais pas
trouvé mais juste avec la sphère du
suicide à un moment donné ça aurait des
chances en rapportant puis il ya eu
pire une info
qui juste que tu eu que deux une version
d'une personne qui raconte une affaire à
mener qui revient jamais mais moi en
finissant en finissant le podcast afin
d' un des derniers épisodes le salafisme
je vois deux options
celle ci ou qui auraient été retrouvées
ça se passe puis
moi j'ai terminé le podcast je me suis
dit
c'est un faux leur est arrivé comme de
façon trop naturelle dans comment la
personne te la raconter
pour que ce soit une pure fabulation une
pure invention dignement en finissant
podcast tout semblait surtout j'avais
une idée assez claire me reste est ce
que moi je me disais what the fuck ses
cheveux je peux te donner un petit peu
d'informations quand même pour pas que
les gens ont l'impression qu'ils sont de
quoi il parle et qu'on l'écouté on va
voir après si dans le fond bon si nelson
nelson y est elle a boy était au sénat
et roscoff dans le milieu de la jungle
amazonienne le thé loin de toutes formes
de civilisation mais l'on sait qu'à un
moment donné il y au prix de l'ayahuasca
ce sont le seul fait cliquer et le
plusieurs jours plus tard ici
enlevez lève il est ici fait infliger
des blessures mortelles avec un avec un
couteau bon devant des gens qui l'ont
apparemment ok bons
lots finalement il ya un moment donné
des versions divergentes à savoir
comment ça s'est passé cette affaire le
lot c'est genre il y en a un qui dit
abel eu une sortie est sorti de sa
chambre puis allait bien puis après ça
il s'est poignardé un autre qui dit non
on l'a retrouvé à telle place c'est et
puis finalement on leur ramener pittis
et de trois
mois c'est sûr que quand j'entends une
affaire de même
en douze heures un détail aussi
fondamentale date un peu le jeu où il
s'est enlevé la vie qu'est ce qui s'est
passé précisément et loto des versions
complètement contradictoire qui danse
que si ces caisses mais la parole des
uns contre la parole de l'autre
fonctionne honnêtement la seule façon
qu'on pourrait avoir la réponse à ce ce
serait
y avait une enquête policière quand elle
est au pérou qui avait eu 10 ans des
entrevues où ils font venir le monde tu
as well tout seul puis toi c'est quoi ta
version parfait toi c'est quoi ta
version parfois c'est quoi comme ils
font rentrer je veux dire on le voit
c'est parce que moi pour moi c'est la
seule affaire qui laisse un doute planer
sur
la nature de décines
pour toi c'est le on a tout un élément
moi j'en parlais de monde autour de moi
puis tout le monde a cru ce sens afin
d'en but pour moi c'est le détail
incriminant on dirait ah ouais ouais tu
vois
moins pour moi par la div
ok c'est super intéressant pis je suis
pas il rien des enseignes ouest parce
que ça arrive assez rapidement dans
série mais il ya une coupe de détail
comme ceux qui sont complètement
contradictoire là des choses tout comme
ok c'est une version le football c'est
soit l'un ou l'autre volet de cette
affaire le de commun comment est-ce que
ça s'est passé je savais le mato
l'illinois qui ont suivi s'ils ont
précédé le tout précédé celui des
versions contradictoires notation
contradictoire c'est quand ils l'ont
retrouvé il y avait les poignées taille
est ok il est encore lotto dix versions
différentes tiens il y en a un il y en a
un qui dit à cet art vie dans telle
circonstance l'autre dit non et que ça
moi le moi personnellement c'est
celle et la fameuse idée qui avait pas
de trace d'hallucinogènes dans son sens
je le dis dès le premier épisode fait
que c'est pas un secret quand la presse
ont contacté le propriétaire du centre
chamanique au pérou il dit il ya eu des
analyses sanguines sur nelson à
l'hôpital et rentrer à l'hôpital quand
il s'est blessé il rentre à l'hôpital et
on fait des analyses sanguines qui y ont
pas trouvé de traces d'ayahuasca dans
son cinq mois là c'est sûr qu'une
centaine si c'est vrai le bain colline
sur clairement sans vie la ville je ne
sais pas pour moi le moi c'était ça mon
appareil photo c'est tout c'est la fin
de la fin du oui était retrouvée et un
mois c'est la fameuse affaire des
analyses sanguines il y en a que c'est
la fin du poignet il y en a d'autres
il y eu un témoignage qui s'arrêtait
fans d'avoir toile où il ya une personne
clé je trouve la personne la personne
qui est dit le commun qu'elles avaient
reculé qu'elle l'avait retrouvée
totalement les gens en fait les
personnes qui étaient sur place au
moment où ça s'est produit en tant que
tel j'ai pas été capables les rejoindre
je peux à lorient d1 sol parce que
honnêtement à quand il demande à qui
j'ai parlé je pense que c'est beaucoup
demander seulement
sur le coup je me disais si tu décevant
pas prêché comme non pas tant que ça non
mais c'est soit tu
puis même la meute ont maintenant que je
parle à une personne qui comme nom moi
j'étais devant lui le camp star ville je
peux tu faire confiance non ce qui
encore le son se ramène à la règle d'un
journaliste que je suis obligé de suivre
il faut que je comprends d'or
l'information les cas limites une
personne qui me dit je t'ai tout seul
avec lui quand il était vital à faire
je sais pas plus mais pendant pas la
presse qui publie un article là dessus a
donné d'information là dessus en ayant
juste une source qui est quelqu'un qui
clairement biaisé dans la sphère me
semble que c'est pas du journalisme si
rigoureux sur ben en fait moi la façon
dont je le perçois l'article la presse
je perçois que c'était probablement une
première c'est une première version un
peu comme des fois le temps tel genre de
meurtre meurtre crapuleux hier sur le
plateau mont royal le tu sais pas qui
ni pourquoi elle aussi un homme tire
féministe un autre féminicide à montréal
puis tout seul le conjoint suspecté mais
imagine que tu as pu jamais d'arctic
apprêtée comme bas le ca aurait été le
fun d'avoir une suite et que je les
blâme pas dans le sens où
ils n'ont pas poursuivi dans ce sens là
peut-être qu'ils ont essayé de
poursuivre ici qu'il n'y avait pas de
piste à l'époque c'est moi y'a eu du
chemin et le débutant à leurs enfants il
y ait des gens là que visiblement il ya
deux ans il voulait pas parler si le
tout d'un coup ils étaient prêts à
parler pour une raison que honnêtement
je m'explique pas encore fait que moi je
trouve que l'article après c'était
correct dans le sens une juste et voici
ce qu'on a comme information en ce
moment c'est plus que quand wet sully
sopi t'accroches com - j'ai accroché cet
article pour moi c'est impensable qui
ait pas de suite à sotchi mais pas de la
faute à brahim c'est peut-être seul
bémol que j'apporterai le fait qu'ils
aient les personnes sur place qui veut
parler que tout le monde qui a travaillé
leur vous souhaitera données vont
changer leur voix chaude et l'eau chaude
a totalement justement d'accord je pense
que c'est même plus large que juste cet
événement rare en temps tellement je te
dirai que j'ai lu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de cols de toutes les incidents
qu'ait eue je te dirai que ce matin là
semble se répéter c'est à dire dans les
centres chamanique au pérou la dernière
chose que tu veux faire c'est à tirer de
la mauvaise attention sur l'ayahuasca
parce que l'économie locale repose
maintenant entièrement là dessus ça
qu'on s'entende su que les gens qui sont
là bol c'est vraiment pas leur avantage
de berlines main pour eux pour leur
propre travail
pour leur sécurité même à la limite qui
est aussi une autre femme surgelés pas
inclus dans le bal à dos parce que
m'emmener loti j'ai encore tellement de
choses à dire mais le pire ou c'est un
des pays que dit assez haut niveau de
corruption va dire et je pense que les
gens là-bas se sentent pas
nécessairement non plus protégé et il
imagine que tu parles a bola est ce que
la police locale va être de ton bord
outils c'est un endroit qui est connue
ce que je délaisse pas controversé en
pensant à aller lire les allées leur
transparency international c'est écrit
noir sur blanc factice je pense que les
gens n'ont pas avantage là bas a parlé
c'est un bateau qui semble se répéter
dans beaucoup d'histoires de décès comme
ça ça prend vraiment longtemps avant
qu'on sache ce qui s'est passé parce que
là bas tout le monde et comme
impo question que je parle
est-ce que
[Musique]
faut revenir bientôt mais j'ai encore
tellement question est-ce que c'est
autant dans la première saison est a
voulu de prêter un peu au jeu est ce que
en rentrant dans la saison 2 il ya eu au
moment où tu t'es dit
faudrait peut-être que je prenne des
psychedelic même 71 pas où tu avais pas
envie août avait peut-être même peur de
tuer sur matadi pour être capable d'en
parler
d'où de parler de l'autre côté mettons
faudrait jambes c'est vous en question
n'ont pas de souci ça descend ça c'est
pop assez pop s'était pas présenté comme
ça en fait moi j'ai commencé en ayant
comme au début de ma démarche n'était
pas question ne surprend tout genre 000
morts mais un moment donné lopy c
c'est pas des enfants que je dis là mais
je dors j'ai écouté toutes les
documentaires que ce sont en fait là
dessus j'ai lu un livre au complet la
tulle d'un journaliste américain qui
s'appelle michael owen qui était un gros
livre sur l'histoire la science des
psychedelic à tige au brûlis de sully de
celui là dessus du balat du monde c'est
sûr qu'avant on était curieux je
trouve que c'est normal comme réaction
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un moment donné
je me souviens d'en marquer il ya
vraiment un moment dans ma quête où je
me disais comme quant à lindsay
acquittement pas de bon sens que je
l'essaie pauvres peut-être que je
devrais comme trouver des champignons
magiques puis juste me faire un enfer
pendant une demi heure puis après ça
sera offerte je pourrais parler avec une
certaine connaissance de la battant
depuis tout ce cette idée là amis venus
thiam a habité pendant ce n'est pas un
petit bouge mais questionné là dessus je
me disais pas peut-être que je devrais
je devrais tu si je parlais aussi
beaucoup c'est le moment où j'ai
commencé à parler à des gens que c'était
plus de la spiritualité ou des enfants
le manège par la demande qui me disent
d'autant plus le nom moi je suis une
personne - la science est important
moins chez une personne malade au monde
super rationnel le qui disent non moi
c'est que mon cerveau là je le sais que
c'est juste des hallucinations mais
quand à l'insee fauqué pareil puis j'ai
le goût de voir qu'est ce que mon
cerveau peut me faire vivre tout ça la
monétique sommes ok finalement ces gens
ne sont pas différents de moins c'est
sont curieux ils cerveau ça les fascine
comme brad pitt avec je l'eus
questionnement là puis honnêtement à man
et à force de travail et après je suis
rentré plus d affaires de nelson piquet
août puis on dirait que ça m'a cassé
puis c'est pas rationnel mon affaire le
sait comme j'ai eu un moment de remise
en question je me suis je devrais tu
viens manger l'envi m'a vraiment partie
solide on peut confier du lot il ya un
monde de différence en forme d'hommage
icm et ont plié à ce que pareil les 1
100 par rapport au lendemain ya pas d
pas de lien la limite le seul dans ton
salon avec ta blonde qui peut appeler
l'ambulance ci arrive de quoi puis elles
dansent dans le milieu de l'art gens qui
s'occupent
totalement puis gelé me je les laissais
ce moment là dans le baladeur je me
questionne là dessus parce que
je trouve que c'est important pour
laquelle pages est une quête personnelle
après la saison qui est de comprendre ma
peur des drogues puis je trouve
certaines réponses sans pouvoir être
certain de tout sujet un historique
familial peut-être non non non puis je
les laissais ce moment là je me suis dit
pas moi même je l'eus questionnement le
fait que c'est pas des caves qui font
cela je dirais moi même année j'ai eu le
goût le puis ça fait que je devrais je
le comprends je comprends pourquoi il ya
un engouement ce moment
puis parlant d'engouement justement ces
visas sont au magic s'il l'on parle de
microdoses à cette prise en touche peu
plus là
c'est quelque chose qui quittent
appartement ou kit eric pige pas le seul
les micros dosage ça c'est vraiment un
autre affaire le complètement mais
complètement différente
une clause âge de manière régulière
mercredi six heures parce que peut-être
pour ceux qui connaissent moins le
concept est depuis le début tout ce
qu'on a dit depuis le début c'est vivre
des expériences psychédéliques profonde
le titre une substance d'alu sine die
bon micro dosage ces différents micros
dosage c'est de prendre des substances
généralement on parle de suspense
puisque et délire qui s'appelle du lsd
des champions magique des canettes
français clerck et aminu un peu importe
qui mais en prennent des toutes petites
doses
puis ça fait aucun effet à lyon aucun
effet au niveau du 6 novembre c'est pas
assez fort mais ils prennent ça comme un
antidépresseur carrément le sais j'en
prends une petite dose à chaque jour qui
j'ai l'impression que ça améliore mon
humeur que ça diminue mon anxiété
des choses comme ça ce mouvement là à ce
moment ci est
immense même moi j'ai parlé à beaucoup
de gens de la communauté d'euskadi que
batman selon qu'ils sont inquiets eux
mêmes le petit monde qui sont à fond
dans les disques et délicat et qui ont
par ailleurs de microdoses argent ce
moment beaucoup d'experts sont
préoccupés mais aussi des gens de la
communauté puisque délit que même le gie
par là entre autres par l'ats la
directrice exécutive de la société
basque avec montréal le pied a dit
honnêtement ça me dépasse cela dit moi
ça s'est rendu plus loin que moi le
moment il me l'a dit comme fer que c'est
complètement non enfin le problème là
dedans c'est dessus la substance en tant
que telle ou si le fait que les gens
sautent aux médicaments dans son décès
en fait c'est un il a ôté les deux parce
que le
raisonnement de tout cela c'est que les
gens se disent balancer des molécules
intéressantes qui ont des effets sur le
cerveau quand tu lis sur internet tous
les justes des affaires positive accuse
dix mois je veux pas être basée à
longueur de journée mais si jean prat
juste des petites doses sans mind bon
la bresse à la question c'est oit matin
mais qu'est ce que ça fait exactement
sur le cerveau ce que ça fait
précisément les psychédéliques on sait
qu'ils agissent au niveau du système
sérotoninergique la sérotonine
savez quel autre mot les quais du
connaissez vous d'autres molécules qui
agissent au niveau de la sérotonine
personnellement non non les ans les
pressant à qui tu es les antidépresseurs
la vaste majorité d'entre eux préfèrent
fonctionne au niveau du système
sérotoninergique les antilles presseur
emmené médicaments sur ordonnance donc
c'est pas si pour [ __ ] penser que les
psychédéliques qui agissent au niveau de
la sérotonine tous avoir un effet à ce
niveau là ok sauf que leur maintenant la
question c'est de se dire est ce que ça
marche pour de vrai puis deux ce que des
risques stylisant titré soir on peut
aimer ou paul qui tue mouche pour un
apologiste danse et pressage pensons
très intéressant pour les bonnes
personnes puis moins dans d'autres cas
mais ça fait quand même 50 ans qu'on les
utilise typique on les étudie en détail
si on les connaît en ce moment là le
micro dosage lilian notre hôte études
liant le pôle puis les premières études
qui ont été faites les y ont commencé à
faire des études bien fait parce que eu
des études qui ont été faites sur le
micro dosage où les gens prennent des
microdoses de champion magique des les
excès terrain des études qui avaient une
méthodologie complètement absurde et
j'oserais exemple je sais pas le jeu
prend vous autres puits 30' de vos amis
je vous donne des microdoses puis je
vous demande ça faisait déjà aidé vous
me répondez oui j'suis comme cool
quelque
80 non mais j'en cite un exemple dans
mon dans mon baladeur judicieux un
magnet une grande étude internationale
qui a révélé que l'ayahuasca qui traite
la dépression et l'anxiété ce qu'on fait
ce qu'ils ont demandé aux gens qui ont
fait de la crise of the dead et 94% déjà
disent oui je crois tu as tu une étude
micro dosage c'est presque toutes les
études c'est ce qu'ils demandent aux
gens est ce que ça vous aide pour
diminuer votre anxiété vraiment mais
quand tu fais des études et qu'un
placebo vraiment une étude ou que les
deux personnes qui donne un truc que je
double aveugle les gens savent pas ce
qu'ils prennent que cette erreur mais en
ce moment on vous il ya pas les faits
je dis pas que dans cinq ans ça va être
la même en fait dans cinq ans mais
comment alors ne plus d'études c'est
qu'on en est maintenant c'est le produit
en ce moment ce convoi succès de l'effet
placebo principalement
puis loeb et maintenant les gens vont
dire des gens qui vont dire on s'en fout
le site de l'effet placebo puis ça me
fait du bien c'est pas grave matin le
problème c'est que ces substances qui
sont associés à dire et ce coup-ci il ya
des risques associés à ces substances la
syrie selon les connais politique en
battant les entrées pressent ce fait 50
ans qu'on les étudier on les connaît les
risques à long terme c'est aix pour ça
qu'on a ajouté les doses on les a baissé
le plus bas possible
les laines le micro dosage on sait que
ça peut avoir des effets cardiaque entre
autres parce qu'on a des récepteurs de
la sérotonine dans nos valves cardiaques
qu'ils en l'absence fois qu on pense que
ça pourrait créer un épaississement des
valves cardiaques par exemple créé des
dommages sur le coeur de façon
permanente ça pourrait être possible
c'est pas hautement probable mais si tu
le laisses tu dis pas tu le sais pas
puis l'autre chose c'est que ça pourrait
causer des dommages aussi neurologique à
long terme c'est je dirais tu agis quand
même sur ton cerveau de change la vci
mythe ton cerveau sucre et là tu fais la
création de nouvelles de nouvelles
connexions neuronales
c'était pas une bonne chose fait que
fait mieux en ce moment moi je trouve ça
assez préoccupant pour être tout à fait
en haïti moi j'aurais envie de dire
étudiants soient vraiment comme faux
puis après on va rôles puis sais pas ce
qui se fait en ce moment a lancé
ses immenses que le micro dosage
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui prennent
soin absolument et puis j'en connais mon
insu de l'argent en sacrement dans cette
danse émoi industrie là aussi ça c'est
l'autre affaire tient en ce moment au 6e
c'est là l'autre arctique est pas le
fond de nos sections on a l'impression
que les psychédéliques le c'est une
affaire de
stoner faire de libé de
didier logis un peu libérale ti-jean
responsable culture hippie puis
anticapitaliste et coûteux très bien
expliqué c'est exactement ça en ce
moment savez-vous qui investit
massivement dans les psychédéliques la
droite amérique la télé pharmaceutique
et la droite américaine ouais ouais
ouais exactement parce qu'il ya qu il ya
vraiment de l'argent faire avec seul
segment industrie de spiritualité le 10e
rang d'une industrie mais c'est plus une
affaire de huy qui le moi ce que je
trouve triste pour les gens c'est qu'en
ce moment les gens sont dans la pire
situation possible parce qu'on imagine
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse au micro deux
otages le quai il va sur internet pour
s'informer belle elle reçoit de
l'information à la fois des milieux dans
de la communauté psychédélique hyper
disons l'adhésion de la frange de la
communauté puisque l'équipe est
enthousiaste en volume trop dosage puis
que peut-être que le fait que des études
soient pas concluante ça les intéresse
pas tant que ça au fait quand ils
reçoivent l'information 2 de locaux
tirent sur l'information qui vient de
grosse business en ce moment qui
investissent massivement l'adaption
intérêt à ce que les gens développent
d'intérêt là dedans le monde est comme
pris en sandwich en deux groupes le qui
n'ont rien en commun mais les deux
veulent la même affaire est ce moi
personnellement c'est sûr que ça me fait
peur
juste pour finir on
je mangeais étudier ça fait plusieurs
fois que le pack agents par les
injections intéresse thomsen le
journaliste panama maîtrise
las vegas dans le fond c'est il s'en va
à une convention de policiers pour la
war on drugs ils s'envolent oeil un
crédit pour aller là puis décide d'y
aller complètement défoncé sur la sim
pour prouver que les policiers ont
aucune idée de ce pourquoi ils se
battent conte ce contre quoi ils se
battent parce qu'on a pas gardé de
reconnaître que ce que l'oeil et sur
l'acide à l'oxygène convention de
comment lutter conte de l'acide puis
puis danser il dit aussi que
une des raisons pourquoi les états unis
ce bateau si fortement plombé les
indices pu prendre un max peu le même
principe maintenant puis tu confirmes
parce que je dis que la claque de
grosses droite américaine si massivement
des psychedelic une des raisons pourquoi
les etats-unis se battre se battait
comme tu sais qui avait pas de côtes
c'est cet excès de la drogue qui venait
d'amérique du sud puis que d'autres n'y
avait pas de corte les états unis très
hâte de faire de taxi-be faire de
l'argent sur la dépendance des gens fait
que c'est quand qu'on pense que l'eau
peut-être les grosses corporations
commencent à investir massivement dans
la découverte de psychédélique qui
apprécie aussi derrière mais totalement
puis peut-être un des messages que
j'aimerais que les gens retiennent t'es
plein de gens qui ont de l'intérêt pour
l'eee psychédélique je trouve ça
complètement légitime qui je lui dis moi
meine juin moment jésus est intéressant
j'aimerais déjà vont vouloir se faire
peut-être cette expérience le mais je
pense qu'il faut vraiment se questionner
en ce moment deux justement qui comme
c'est quoi le meilleur contexte leur
utilisation si si je pense que le risque
en ce moment c'est être deux pour
réaliser toutes les forces justement qui
sont qui sont en jeu pad en lien avec
sortie donc s'il ya beaucoup de gens
dans le monde et psychédélique que deux
qui milite depuis les années 60 70
depuis que la réglementation est déjà
qui milite depuis 50 ans pour qui la
recherche scientifique hockey dans la
communauté psychédélique le
historiquement c'est des gens qui ont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup milité pour
qu'il y ait de la science
est aujourd'hui le depuis quelques
années là il ya un revirement de
situation les ja qui militait pour
qu'ils aient plus d'études cliniques et
plus de sciences il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vire de bord en disant oh non parce
que là tu un peu plus au delà de l'étude
pluie de la recherche là dessus ben plus
les compagnies pharmaceutiques c'est eux
qui vont s'emparer d'autres substances
ça correspond pas avec mes valeurs et
que ça amène une sorte de situation un
peu faux cul puis je pense que peut-être
juste pour ajouter un peu de perspective
je pense que les psychédéliques pour
qu'on puisse les utiliser je pense que
ce qui est important c'est qu'on puisse
les utiliser de façon sécuritaire peu
importe que ce soit l'ayahuasca houle
lsd whatever le temps d'évoquer plein de
problèmes aujourd'hui l'épreuve de
qualité sur la rue c'est les risques que
ces thérapies tout de suite c'est fake
je pense que c'est autant on peut dire
décriminaliser ça pourrait être une
avenue intéressante mais je pense que le
fait que ce soit étudié scientifiquement
oui c'est soit tu vas y avoir des
dérapages puis oui c'est sûr qu'il ya
des grosses business qui vont comme ça
arrive et c'est heureux mais l' avantage
qui vient avec soin par contre c'est que
si tout cela se met en branle depuis que
ça marche mais éventuellement tu vas
avoir des thérapeutes des psychologues
qui vont pouvoir recevoir des gens en
cabinet puis qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
vivre des expériences psychédéliques à
des gens dans un contexte où ils vont
pouvoir vraiment bénéficié puis il y
aura poids un endoctrinement de côté
possédées par des demandes des enfants
infectés je pense que c'est important de
pouvoir tout noir ou tout blanc là où
c'est sûr que c'est avenue le de
capitalistes de marchandisation a le
désavantage mais je pense que c'est
quand même
façon quand même l'aspect monétaire même
studio pérouges aussi ce mot
exact mais reste maintenant la personne
qui sonne qui méfiant de la science la
personne qui anticapitaliste si lipsky
des lic devienne comme un peu plus
institutionnalisé peut s'accepter un peu
plus étudié scientifiquement
peut-être tourné par la nouvelle affaire
qui est la nouvelle affaire alternative
pourquoi puisque je dis probablement
comme il les yeux il ya une partie de la
traire l'impression de tous et dans le
fixe alternatif
ben je pense que oui dit-il à ce moment
j'ai lu pendant que je faisais le balade
ou dans les derniers mois la première
étude sur le composant d'une angine
l'ayahuasca qui s'appellerait en bleu
dmt le banc la première étude a été
lancée en angleterre je pense donc le
cite une étude clinique qu'avec du dmt
double aveugle placebo pour le coup
c'est moins cool
depuis une cérémonie impudicité ça fait
là sur le coup c'est cool la presse
comme à mende l'ayahuasca qui me faisait
triper au pérou dans jungle de coups
s'est rendue une affaire qu'on donne
d'handicap cela du côté spirituel qui
expliqué qu'ils étaient recherchés nom
puis moi je me demande si ça vaut pas
nier si je me demande s'il est en fait
je me suis vraiment demandé puis j'ai
pas la réponse encore aujourd'hui est-ce
que l'ayahuasca et dissociable du rituel
auquel il appartient je suis pas sûr
l'avenir le dira la maison elsa dérive
saison 3
j'aimerais ça sent trop je m'en sois là
j'ai besoin d'un break un peu gênant et
deux saisons alain delon puis j'ai pas
le temps le temps de réfléchir beaucoup
mais j'ai décidé oui j'en ai plein ah
ouais c'est pas le problème c'est pas le
manque d'idées c'est plus comme sur les
pelles à laquelle idée que j'ai envie de
mettre un âne ma vie puis de comme
penser à soi en m'endormant
genre de vivre une obsession la qualité
la moins nuisibles d'être obsédé par way
ou laquelle qui me fait triper ou qui me
passionne ou faut vraiment que tu sois
faut juste que tu sois habités par leur
faire de même pour pouvoir investir
dedans l'elysée fait que je me laisse un
peu de temps pour y penser mais
j'aimerais vraiment ce moment peut
contrer mais mettons comment de tant de
personnalités honnêtement il faut pas
que je le mets ton je suis 3 les semis
par semaine mais ton pendant un an quand
même tenté mineurs d'âge mais je dois y
est en plein attendre là dessus à temps
plein
comme si ma tante journée je pouvais pas
parce que j'avais un tournage pour la
série télé ou taf a rejeté comme parfait
mais lendemain je travaille se baladent
au lycée mais c'est comme aux autres si
je voudrais comme cette passionnée si
vous êtes deux par deux passionnés josé
cambou triste quoi le viala font mouche
même aussi fait que ça a pas l'air du
travail m'apprenant tenté comme
en ce moment les gens avides et comme
dit de me coucher en boule un peu le
pido jusqu'en mai mais à ce moment là
j'ai envie de jouer à des jeux vidéo le
malade le sait c'est mon avis et si j'ai
envie de chile d'un problème en cas au
mois de janvier le lait ouais c'était
tsl va réapparaître coup merci beaucoup
toujours vraiment moussa à du contenu
excellent tu as tout un pataquès
convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre le pitch vous abonner pour
trop de l'or parmi six autres au delà
ouais trois pièces par morlaàs par mois
et vous avez les pas de carte en avance
acquise avec les premiers de votre
groupe d'amis à recruter les podcasts
qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une
avance quand vous allez tirer la
dynamique entre les amys tout le temps
avec une avance sur les jobs en avance
les entre deux toits mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le ch
et le podcast unis voulu nous en dire
davantage on fait des encore moins de
filtres à préchac podcast mec là on
vient de finir de tourner le poker on va
en jaser en match amical non nicolas
maintenant comme un fils travaille la
place de temps à taille est là mais on
jase on parle de conversion qu'on m'aide
à voir mais ce si vous voulez avoir
accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétrole il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous